no all right so we still have five
minutes of adjusting to do on that
directed vertigate motion may be made at
any time and okay we're ready to do that
right now I don't think it'll be
affected by the exhibits all right great
and just for the record because I think
it'll speed things up if we can sure Mr
Bueller um I guess whoever's going to
make the motion and just make those or
would you like me to stand up why don't
you come up here so I can
okay
thank you your honor this motion is a
motion for directed verdict on Miss
Paltrow's claim for attorneys fees
under Utah code
78b5 825 attorney's fees
are only available in Utah
where there is an action or defense in
bad faith in civil actions as you're
aware your honor there's only attorneys
fees to a prevailing party if the if the
court determines that the action or
defense was without Merit and not
brought or asserted in good faith these
are two independent requirements
they have not been met in this case as
the courts aware we filed a motion for
summary judgment earlier on in the case
when your honor was not the presiding
judge that was denied based on
um questions that the judge had
regarding the press conference that was
held and so what I want to talk about
first is the standard for
the court to utilize in the bad faith
statute it is narrowly drawn and it's
not meant to be applied to all
prevailing parties in all civil suits an
action or defense is without Merit if it
is frivolous if it is of little weight
or importance having no basis in law or
fact or clearly lacks a legal basis for
recovery
finding of bad faith turns on a factual
determination of a party's subjective
intent
a party acts in bad faith when he brings
an action
or defense and either lacks an honest
belief in the propriety of the
activities in question
intends to take unconscionable advantage
of others or intends to or has knowledge
of the fact that his actions will hinder
delay or defraud others
so therefore your honor an unmeritorious
action if the if that's how this turned
out and who knows that's up to the jury
an unmeritorious action may still be in
good faith as long as there is an honest
belief that it is appropriate and as
long as there is no intent to hinder
delay to fraud or take advantage of the
other party
that's what's key in this particular
case your honor
as the courts aware the reason for
awarding attorney's fees based on bad
faith is to punish the wrongdoer not to
compensate the victim and that fee
should therefore only be awarded upon
specific evidence of bad faith
there is no specific evidence there is
no evidence of bad faith in this case
this is clearly a he said she said ski
accident we've heard the testimony of
witnesses of eyewitnesses Mr Sanderson
had an independent witness that saw the
accident there were also
experts who have testified that because
of the location of his ribs rib injuries
that he had to have been struck from
behind by Miss Paltrow
there's clearly and obviously the
defense has their own side of the story
but there is clearly a
evidence-based support for
his claims in this case
further
his damages
the damages are clear there's no dispute
that he sustained four broken ribs and
then obviously there's the claims for
the brain injury yesterday there was a
great deal of medical testimony that was
brought by the defense they all agreed
that Mr Sanderson was not malingering so
he is not you know fraudulently or
lying about his injuries in whatsoever
Miss Paltrow from the very beginning has
brought this claim for bad faith and
attorney's fees as a weapon to try and
compel Mr Sanderson to dismiss this case
as I said the summary judgment was
denied because of this allegation this
loose allegation that well there was a
press conference so we've now heard from
the defense there has been nothing no
evidence brought forth by the defense
that the press conference was brought to
take advantage of Ms Paltrow's celebrity
or that it was in bad faith in fact the
only evidence regarding the press
conference was brought through my
questioning of Mr Sanderson and he
testified that it was his personal
injury Council that held the press
conference that it was their idea and
that the purpose of that press
conference was to seek to find witnesses
to the accident
many that sought to exclude evidence
that related or I don't know I don't
remember what the Motions saw it but the
result of it was an order from the court
saying that
evidence that relates solely to the bad
faith claim isn't part of the jury trial
and so the court was contemplating that
there would be that that if the jury
found
for the defendant
that the court would take additional
evidence on the bad faith issues or
those that related solely to the bad
faith
was that your understanding as well and
what do you think what are your thoughts
on that well I think your honor that
there's been sufficient evidence that
has come through this
in through the trial that there is no
evidence of bad faith there it's a very
very high standard to meet and
there's there's so much evidence here
that shows it is clearly a he said she
said case this was not based on Mr
Sanderson trying to have an ill motive
um and there's a great deal of case law
that I could go into but I don't want to
take the Court's time right now on that
um I I just I think that the evidence
that has been presented has been very
clear that there is no bad faith in this
case that they could not Prevail on that
and at this point I really think that a
directed verdict on the attorney's fees
would be appropriate okay thank you
Mr Owens
do you have well first of all I had two
questions do you have more evidence
other than what came in here today to
support a bad faith claim and number two
um isn't the fact that you're directed
verdict motion was denied evidence that
there is a basis for the plaintiff's
claims yes and yes okay
I was precluded from talking about this
stuff by their motion so I can't be
handcuffed and then slapped uh I need to
be able to defend a claim I specifically
wanted to talk about this stuff but
based on Kristen's motion I couldn't and
now I shouldn't be slapped down about it
I would take the motion under advisement
Miss Orman I'd like to hear what
additional evidence the defense has on
the issue
may I ask when you anticipate doing that
at a later date or would that is that
today at a later date well I guess it
depends I mean if ah today
when the verdict comes in then we can
make a decision about when to hear the
additional evidence
I remember raising this issue and said
your honor did you envision then
remember that a later hearing right at a
time convenient to the parties yes thank
you Mr Bueller
good morning your owner on the issue of
spoliation there's a jury instruction
and we believe there's been no shred of
evidence presented in this case
that the plane have had a GoPro video he
denied he had a GoPro video the only
evidence is an email from his daughter
who says oh I can't believe there
there's a GoPro
and uh
his daughter as well Shea yeah that's
who I'm referring but that doesn't mean
I mean it could be anyone that had the
GoPro video could have been the Deer
Valley could have been anyone but
there's just absolutely no evidence it
was a mistake and uh it would be
absolutely erroneous if the Court gives
this jury instruction
because other than that mentioned in
that email which uh
um the defense and there's been no
evidence that at all brought in this
case that there's anything to it
um is uh would be will be uh
clearly erroneous and uh therefore we
request that the spoliation issue be
stricken from uh the the instructions as
it would Prejudice the plaintiff on
something that has no basis has not been
proven they have nothing in fact uh the
late produced
meetup.com comments
verify that because the defense had been
saying or implying or insinuating that
oh the GoPro video must be in that stuff
because it was mentioned in that same
email chain with
the daughter Shea and there's just
nothing there okay thank you thank you
so I'm going to deny the directed
verdict motion on the spoliation
instruction the defense uh have you
reviewed the instruction there's a new
one that came out moving the word
removing the word the from the bottom
it's acceptable okay and
Mr Bueller
um
I mean you're certainly welcome to to to
submit a request to the court some
additional interrogatory so that it's
clear from the record whether the jury
made findings under spoliation or not
I think it could track the instruction
itself that way
if there's a verdict that's adverse to
your client you would know whether the
spoliation and structure whether whether
there was any inference taken by the
jury
on the GoPro video Yeah it gives more
Credence to the
to the lack of evidence of this
so we'll consider that and I guess we
would have to do that pretty darn quick
yes we would I think I think that the
daughter Shea testified that when she
got off the phone she thought there was
a GoPro video and I think reasonable
inference from that the jury could could
decide
that there was a GoPro video and that
your client had some control over that
video they could make that decision
right but it there was no evidence that
he had control over it it was just there
was one it was mentioned and uh
means that every time a piece of
evidence that's mentioned that turns out
to not have any basis then it becomes a
spoliation issue we think that's uh an
erroneous level of proof I've got two
others or excellent and then finally
I'll uh do you mind if I go ahead now
you're on this go ahead okay
on the issue of negligence and I'm going
to talk about both defendants negligence
and plaintiff's negligence
on defendants negligence uh at least for
the record
we assert that there is there should be
a directed verdict on liability
causation and damages
and that is that is based on the
evidence that's been brought before the
court
likewise on the plaintiff side we on the
defendant side we should have a directed
verdict in favor of the plaintiff on the
plaintiff side the
charges from the defense against the
plaintiff
on the issues of liability causation and
damages
should also be brought and uh I could
summarize the whole case but I don't
think it's necessary I think the court
realizes that but if you'd like I could
add more detail for the basis of that
directed verdict motion two of them
yes the one dollar that
who would owe you that's the second one
the first one is a directed verdict in
our favor for our damages our liability
causation and the only issue would be
the amount of the damage is for us
so I combined them too so it's actually
two directed verdicts with three
subparts each liability causation and
damages and I have given it some thought
anticipating your motion
and and based on my my review of The
Evidence I would deny uh all both
motions with all three parts in both
motions okay thank you Arnold then I
have one other it's not a directed
verdict motion but it's a
it's a motion um
uh to take judicial notice of Terry
sanderson's life expectancy according to
the um
Social Security Administration life
expectancy tables and calculation this
is something that's commonly done I'll
just advise the defense that we're
planning to use in our closing reference
to the life expectancy of Terry to
calculate a per diem have you have you
disclosed to them what number that you
plan to use
um yes I'm ready to do that right now
it's they change with each day right and
uh
and I've got one for report too in
principle does the defense have any
issue with that well
he's got 20 some odd health conditions
some of which are uh
impact life expectancy so I I am problem
but I have some problems about it but
it'd be nice to know what they want yeah
we're actually going to go lower than
that would you like to approach sure 10
additional years
yeah just 10 years even though it says
10.8
you'd be argument that Terry's uh you
know he's a non-smoker
you know he has other health
factors in his favor that he's conscious
about his health and so we just want to
in argument in closing argument mention
that
he has a
potential life expectancy of this and
then argue that on a per diem basis for
his future
non-economic damages non-economic
damages as you know are not precisely
derived they have it's more of a
subjective Viewpoint of the jury and the
party's arguments in favor of
to address the defendant's issues with
you know the
the
comorbidities let's call them they
cannot do that too I realize they can
argue that but how about to address that
if what the court takes judicial notice
of is that a person who is 76 years old
has an approximate life expectancy based
on the Social Security tables of 10
additional years yes is that your honor
that way I'm not I'm not taking judicial
notice of
plaintiff's life expectancy but rather
what the Social Security tables say
write your honor and I'll give you five
uh here as it relates to Terry let me I
know what they are Council let me just
say this I don't plan to or we don't
plan to reference this the Social
Security tables it would be just as
simple that a statement that Terry's
life expectancy could be calculated at
approximately 10 years and the past
seven years since the trial date it's
like taking cognizance of the that
conclusion because it involves an
individual
oh you don't have to make the conclusion
I'm just more you just laid it out I
would
well what I'm I don't I'm just
previewing what the closing argument
will mention
and that it's not and it's not evidence
in the case it's argument it's if I'm
taking judicial notice of it it is
evidence well
I I don't think the court needs to take
judicial notice but if the court would
like that we we did produce this I'm
just letting giving you a preview in the
defense Council that we will be making
this argument that uh he could
potentially have 10 years of life and
that uh That's the basis for our damage
claim and then it's
not raising it to the level of something
evidentiary it's it's pure argument
for calculating
non-economic damages okay
Mr Owens I don't I don't have an
objection to your honors uh approach
which is under Social Security tables
70s
six-year-old man is expected to live 10
more years and Mr Buehler's not is
proposing that that not what happened
that they just refer to it in closing
argument I mean not that they don't
refer to any particular table but they
just say
you know a man at his age he's probably
got about 10 years do you have any
objection to that
in its argument but if the court is
inclined to not prohibit the plaintiff
from making that argument then we would
ask that the court take judicial notice
of what I just gave you they
can argue it and they can argue it okay
so you can argue it without any
reference to the table or me taking any
judicial notice West Council wants
reference to it or the court does
I want to if you're going to talk about
Terry I'll stipulate to five
okay then just we'll keep it as argument
okay which which brings up a very
important point I wanted to raise
um there have been a lot of evidentiary
objections during the trial that uh that
that a particular question misstates
test prior testimony in the case
um I don't want what I want to avoid is
a lot of that kind of objection
happening during closing argument that
hey he's he's not saying what really
happened here in trial or he's
misstating what really happened here in
trial
um I would I would I would not I I don't
want to see a lot of that objection
during closing arguments because my
reaction will be the same as it has been
throughout the trial the jury will
remember what people said so if you
think that the other lawyer or lawyers
say things that aren't supported in the
record then bring that up in your part
of the argument
and so what because what I expect you to
do with this one exception of this
10-year thing I expect you to tether
your arguments to the evidence that was
in front of the jury and any reasonable
inferences from them
not to bring in outside data not to
bring it outside
evidence but just the evidence that was
here in this courtroom
okay just to give you a sample we would
argue that Terry has
approximately 10 years left at least in
his life he's lived a healthy he's uh
act he's not you know non-smoker and
there's not any objection to that thank
you okay turning now to the jury
instructions does anyone wish to object
to any of the closing jury instructions
that the court put together
we're reviewing them uh I know you gave
them to us yesterday
give us one moment please the only one
that we might have a small suggested
change or objection to your honors
exfoliation
sorry it's the spoliation instruction we
have here okay it's that first sentence
uh we don't believe that there's been
any evidence that Mr Sanderson was in
possession of a GoPro and so we would
want the first sentence to be changed to
miss Paltrow has presented evidence that
a GoPro video of the ski Collision may
have existed
Sanderson asserts at the GoPro video of
the ski Collision never existed so be
because there's been no evidence put on
that he possessed it there's been an
inference of that maybe at best but it's
again coming through his daughter's
email to him
I think that's a reasonable request
evidence of his possession it's more
neutral I think
so it would read now miss Paltrow has
presented evidence that a GoPro video of
the ski Collision may have existed
period and everything else Remains the
Same yeah okay
any other objections from the plaintiff
to the jury instructions
okay
how about the defense
your honor one thing I noted on the
violation of a safety law instruction
the last sentence reads if you decide
that Mr Sanderson and or Miss Paltrow
did not violate safety law you must
disregard the violation and I'm thinking
maybe that should read safety law
because in the prior Clause there's no
violation
thank you
that's correct
and then I did not include the inherent
risk of skiing that the defendant
requested is that one that you're are
you dropping that request or would you
like me to give my reasoning why
we want it and we would like your
reasoning okay
here's my reasoning so the defendants
have requested a jury instruction that
was entitled The inherent risk of skiing
and they were basing that on Utah code
78b-4-401 and what follows as well as
the Donovan versus Sutton case and so
the courts reviewed those very carefully
a plaintiff asserting that a statute and
there are certain basically they're
asserting that this statute provides
support for the applicable standard of
care
or that relates to the standard of care
in a tort claim and if if a party is
planning or is asserting that they must
demonstrate that the purpose of the
statute was to protect a class of
persons of which the plaintiff in this
case is a member
or the parties in this case are a member
and to protect them against injury or
death resulting from the kind of harm
contemplated by the legislature and that
comes from the colossimo versus Gateway
uh
case
the further a plaintiff must show that
the law was intended to protect persons
in the plaintiffs or the defendant's
shoes from the type of harm that befell
them
so the Utah code
78b-4-401
the inherent risks of skiing Act is not
a safety statute
as
ism is as is anticipated to be read
through a jury instruction
but a limitation of liability Statute in
which the person's protected are ski
area operators not skiers the ACT is not
affording any protection to the skiers
against in against injury which is the
type of harm at issue here
so looking specifically at this
instruction as it has been submitted to
the court
the court believes that this inherent
risk of skiing proposal this during
instruction proposal
circumvents the proper application of
the elements of a cause of action for
negligence to the extent it allows the
jury to reach a result without following
the principles set out in the usual
negligence instruction
it also creates a substantial potential
for confusing and misleading the jury a
jury could rely on a more General
understanding of inherent risk of skiing
and that it is simply an unfortunate and
unavoidable injury-causing event for
which there is no responsibility even
though under traditional tort Concepts
the accident was caused by negligence
compounding this confusion is the
implication that the inherent risk of
skiing constitutes a second ground of
non-liability and instruction carries a
substantial risk this instruction
carries a substantial risk of diverting
the attention of the jury from the
primary issue of negligence
and as a signif and has a significant
chance of creating the impression in the
minds of the jurors of a second hurdle
that the plaintiff must overcome if he
is to prevail
this instruction creates a spurious
additional issue in the case when in
fact the sole issue is the presence or
absence of negligence
approximately causing the accident
the jury is faced with complex
conflicting and less than compelling
evidence and the imprecise rules of
causation and comparative fault create a
significant temptation to abandon a
rigorous application of the negligent of
the instruction and the elements of
negligence and the burden approved and
return a verdict based on the simple
notion that an accident was an inherent
risk of skiing or somehow unavoidable
apart from the inherent confusion the
instruction tends to re-emphasize the
defendant's theory of the case that the
defendant was not negligent to that
extent the instruction then constitutes
an inappropriate judicial comment on the
evidence
of course there are collisions caused by
the inherent risk of skiing for which
the defendant or defendants are not
negligent
in such cases if supported by the
evidence the defendant can certainly
argue that they were not negligent
and that the accident was the result of
the an inherent risk of skiing
and I think this that would be
appropriate argument in this case so
defense can certainly argue inherent
risk of skiing there's been evidence of
inherent risk of skiing they can argue
that neither party was negligent and
this was
purely an accident
and that neither party was negligent but
in terms of the Court Reading the
instruction those would be the reasons
why I've declined to do so
your honor I actually misspoke earlier I
think I've got one thing that I just
noticed to other instructions if we're
ready to move on sure
um on your instructions page 16
Mitigation Of damages
uh I believe the second sentence
that says any damages awarded should not
include those that could have I think
been avoided needs to be added in there
thank you
does the do the defendant have any other
exceptions they want to take to the jury
instructions
it's your honored thanks we yesterday
are you okay if I sit here sure uh
yesterday
your honor granted a directed verdict on
behalf of the defendant on the issue of
post-collision Hit and Run
help me if I'm missing something but we
previously provided to the court the
defendants proposed instruction 45.
entitled Gwyneth Paltrow did not hit and
run and flee the scene
I have a copy it's marked up if you want
it I've got it here
uh denial of the directed verdict um
it doesn't use the word hit and run and
what we talked about yesterday was
post impactors post-crash conduct
is still relevant to the
yeah the failure to render Aid portion
of the ordinance is still being read
it's the failure to give a phone address
and
contact information that was that was
directed out so if you have an
instruction that relates to that I'd be
glad to consider that and it also
included Dr goldstein's testimony
that was also the basis to demonstrate
the uh the
availability of the post crash
actions or events
so do you have do you have another
instruction that's more closely tailored
I think the first sentence of the two
sentences
so your honor chose to split the issue
and
uh and this is the heading so the first
sentence is what we want I have already
determined that Gwyneth Paltrow did not
hit and run and acted
uh
maybe that's the extent of it your honor
I think that's inappropriate it's it's
pre-loading an issue that what isn't an
issue uh it's not something that we're
asserting and that there's
the motion and Lemony stands for and uh
we think that you know we could put in a
lot of things on both sides that are at
this stage uh irrelevant and distracting
there's been
evidence as well as our argument well
opening statement and
cross-examination implying that the
defendant
left the scene without giving in
violation of some ordinance or some
requirement that she gave her contact
information so I what I could read is
that I have already determined that
Gwyneth Paltrow did not leave the scene
of the accident without giving her
contact information
that's reasonable your honor
any other from the defendant any other
exceptions yes your honor and you did
rule on this so I don't want to irritate
you but
deer Valley's Resorts dismissal I I do
like the words for no payment
and this was previously argued I'm
rendering an objection uh
I always get a kick out of this our idea
it's so obvious we don't have to say it
well then why don't we just say it
it's noted I mean the instructions
already been read it's in the opening
instructions
any others
uh your honor I've had a lot of paper
thrown at me is the oral argument is the
excuse me jury instruction that says if
you find
that there was no negligence you can
disregard the remaining damages uh
instructions
you'll see that and when we get to the
special verdict form
it's incorporated into the special
verdict form it indicates that if you
find no negligence on the part of either
party you sign and date the form and
turn it into the court
so I think in the opening instructions
it said something to that effect
there is a standard Muji that says
I'm now going to instruct you on damages
if you find that there's no negligence
you should disregard these instructions
okay yeah that's it looks like it's on
the introduction to torque damages page
I think it's 12 or 13 in your packet
the mother's conference okay
turning to the special verdict form I
realize you just got my version of it
have you had a chance to decide whether
this meets your needs
I took this from the Florida
claim counterclaim the verdict form I
took the the concepts here
your honor
oh you've printed it sorry I was looking
on my email I see thank you
did you get that Mr Bueller yes we did
and we're just wondering if
before closing argument we could get
another copy because two Council I think
sure
yeah I just wanted to there's there's
one change that I think I I might need
to address with you whenever you're
ready
uh and then we'll have to print out new
copies
this is the second exact copy
thank you Johnny
I mean we can wait to look at this until
uh with just before reading jury
instruction because I would like to read
this to the jury during that part of
things
if you're not quite ready
uh can we tell you in two minutes sure
the what I can tell you when you're
ready it's the one change that I see
two-thirds of the way down on page two
when you go when you get past when you
get to the bottom of the comparative
fault questions there's that separate
section
just just above the damages line it says
if Terry sanderson's fault is 50 or more
rather than proceed to question nine
because that one's already filled in
I suggest that we just say sign and date
the form and
turn it into the court
[Music]
that's to address our counterclaim yep
am I thinking that through right on the
comparative fault if Terry sanderson's
fault is less than 50 percent
then you answer the damages question
if it's 50 or more
you just sign and date it and that means
that the one dollar that's been assigned
to Gwyneth Paltrow is the is the counter
claim
um
it doesn't necessarily mean that if
Terry's fault is uh 50 or more that the
defendants uh
doesn't have 50 or more either
you know stuff happens inherent risk of
skiing accidents happen
uh the jury could
deny awarding the one dollar to miss
Paltrow so
well if if they put 50 50 on the compare
default questions
yeah then it would uh but no recovery
for either side right right but there's
the possibility of
um
you know I guess they'd have to do that
exactly but if there's this other is
that is that what we're thinking the
co-counsel
in other words I guess what I'm saying
is I think there's enough information in
these answers to help us
to to uh create a judgment based on any
scenario of that they come up with
um
to me your honor as well but I just want
to make sure
that sometimes a flow chart is helpful
yeah that's true wouldn't it be nice if
one of the questions
or it's important obviously that one of
the questions allows them to connect
Terry sanderson's fault uh to the con
um say that it caused Miss Paltrow's
damages and do you see that as covered
by comparative fault questions
because number four just asks whether
his fault is a cause of his own arm not
of Miss Paltrow's harm
so you just want to make sure that
cousin I see that question is addressed
should should four read just like two
that was my thought and then the
comparative fault questions address
whether
Terry Terry sanderson's
uh fall caused his own harm or to what
extent in other words if if a party's
fault caused the other party's harm
is that sufficient
or do we need another question or does
that question need to be modified to say
was a party's fault a cause of their own
and the other person's harm
the other party's hard
how would you like that to read
I'm fine with it just you know with us
re redrafting for to read like question
two
any
self-harm is captured by the comparative
fault questions
that seems reasonable that seems
reasonable to us too okay
so the question four we'll read now was
Terry sanderson's fault a cause of
Gwyneth Paltrow's harm
your honor the the title of these
sections Gwyneth Paltrow questions
that
should it be like defendant Gwyneth
Paltrow questions or should we eliminate
that at all I'm just posing that as a
question because it seems kind of uh
she's not asking that we're asking that
the vice versa questions on Gwyneth
Paltrow yeah under above number one is
the title underline in bold says Gwyneth
Paltrow questions just take the word
questions out
I just um
it makes it sound like one they're
asking it but in reality we're asking
was Gwyneth Paltrow at fault not Gwyneth
Paltrow so how about if we just label it
Gwyneth Paltrow
right does it need a title
I think it helps direct their attention
that we're talking about her her actions
right
let's eliminate the word questions on
each of the headings yeah
do that
because it implies that she's asking
that and
and I can also delete it on under
compare default and we'll just call it
compare default
nine just for one moment yes
we're nitpicking but uh Judge Tom Green
used to say if we don't get this right
we get nothing right so number eight uh
I just
what if we said what amount fairly
compensates Terry Sanders for
non-economic damages
there's a bullet point that I don't
understand yeah I took this off of the
plaintiff's form that's that's the way
the standard Muji does it but it does it
when there are more than one category
true so yeah that could simply be added
to the
to it for none and on the only thing I
thought about was that it clearly it
clearly says non-economic damages and
there is a jury instruction
that is entitled that as well as the
number nine clearly says
economic damage and there is a jury
instruction entitled economic damage and
for the
economic damages jury instruction
perhaps it should just say
uh Gwyneth Paltrow seeks one dollar
I don't think they need to even
need this big instruction on economic
damages what are the plaintiffs want on
economic damage
well I think the I as the court pointed
out I think we already have the
instruction we've been working on the
instructions for a while we we like to
have it in there and I think it clearly
clearly indicated here on this special
verdict what I like about it Mr Owens is
that it distinguishes the non-economic
damage and then number nine I would just
say what amount fairly compensates
Gwyneth Paltrow for economic for
economic damages
I uh Delete the bullet point and the dot
dot dot okay
it's a plane up okay with the leading
bullet points and the dot dot dots
and the empty space to the right the
blank
s on eight I think it's just this is
unaligned this is on nine eight and nine
just take out the bullet point and the
dots
yeah and then what's what's the this
business of a blank space
under where they're I think number eight
there's a missing line to fill out
that for damages for Terry Sanderson
I'm not following you you want to blank
after the dollar sign
no what no there was just
the line underneath
and fill out on question
nine it doesn't matter agreed that line
shouldn't be there
I'll do my best
they are they're tables
so why don't we take just a short
restroom break Mr Sykes is now here good
morning and then we'll bring the jury in
can I mention one thing sure we filed
the pre-trial motion on rebuttal
Witnesses uh number 12 defense pre-trial
12. it was granted
it sought to give you a little bit of a
bench brief on the narrow scope of
rebuttal Witnesses in short they are not
to just read
State anything that could have been
stated in their case in Chief
I even had a
judge in Logan literally say you can ask
like eight questions and he can say yes
or no with one sentence I mean and I was
on and off in about three minutes
because those were the only brand new
issues that they couldn't have proven
predicted and so we asked that this
rebuttal witness be strictly limited
um
it's not used as an opportunity for the
plaintiff to just uh
restate and sort of get the last word on
things that
so we talked about this when the motion
came up and the court agreed that these
are rebuttal Witnesses they're not to
strike off in a new territory they're
not to clarify there to respond
correct they're just the issues that
came up in the defendants
case
and then of course on the counter claim
all right brand new that's all basically
three questions your honor and who's the
next Witness
so Richard Bain we're just waiting for
him to get on the zoom okay
while you do that then we'll take a
short recess thank you
Islam
unless unless it takes longer to get him
on the zoom
let us let the bailiff know as soon as
you get him on the zoom
can you hear me
I I'm not instructors
may be seated
are we ready to bring the jury in
okay
all right
thank you
very much would you mind speaking to us
for just one second
how do you guys
ready for the jury
test
here sure
okay I hear you guys
so have you read
looks like the video is a little slow
we'll have your audio
thank you thank you
prior to that
say would Council approach the bench uh
I need to show you
foreign
good morning members of the jury sorry
for the delay just be assured that we've
been working very hard and I think the
rest of the morning as a result is going
to go much smoother and much faster so
thank you
Mr Bueller
Blaine of Terry Sanderson calls Dr
Richard Bame on rebuttal
Mr Beam I'm not sure if you can see me
this is Judge Holmberg speaking if you
could please raise your right hand to be
sworn in as a witness
I do not see you I just see my
do you swear that the testimony you were
about to give in the case now before the
court will be the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truths will help you
God
once again uh Dr babe if you could State
your full name and spell it please
as Richard Baines spelled b-o
I think that's b-o-e-h-m-e
can you hear me Dr Bain
I can hear you loud and clear okay thank
you I understand you're on vacation and
we appreciate your time
uh Dr Bain yes
Dr baby in trial testimony this week the
defendants expert Dr Irvine sure
disputed your findings regarding the ski
collision between Terry Sanderson and
Gwyneth Paltrow on February 26 2016.
have you had a chance to read his trial
testimony
did you say something
I have I've read his okay
uh doctors were losing a few of them
worse there yes
so uh maybe Dr Bame if you would uh
start off your uh speech with something
that will then kick in the audio so it
here so here's my answer something like
that before you answer
a a Roger that
okay
Dr sure suggests that you made an error
in your calculations how would you
respond to his suggestion
here is my answer
Dr share mischaracterized my analysis
which led to his analysis being
misleading and incorrect
okay uh
should you ex
did you explain that in more detail what
the analysis is that uh you want to
correct
sure
well Dr share first wrote up the
impact Wars
formulas
and he labeled one of them wrong and one
of them correct
and both of them are wrong
and why first of all
the equation f equals one fmd squared
over d
where he substituted one half a t
squared or one half a t and then eight T
in the parentheses for velocity
you can't do that without uh solving or
time or t first basically what you have
from a mathematical standpoint
you have a force and time which you
don't know so you have two unknowns in
one equation so basically the equation
is unsolvable so you have to first solve
for time
and I you guys have
um
there so if you go over to the first one
where you have x equals x zero plus B
zero t plus one half a t squared
you have to know the height at which Mr
Sanderson fell to the ground Dr Ben
could you share your screen and show us
your calculation
uh either
a year and I'm trying to figure
have it let's
pull it up
over here
do you have it not yet we'll try to
share it here
just give us a second and blur our
screen just a second I'm going to show
it to you
what
all right
she's just got it he's got it okay
all right I'm just
had to unblower my spirit show it to you
but
for my exhibit
zero plus
a t squared
per time
so the height at which
Sanderson
which is X
for t
and you can see that
less than a
four or six
okay
the second
are you substitute
in for
determine the
who are following
falling downward
we know Engineers because it's Earth
everywhere on this
oh if you Dr babe we're having trouble
hearing you um if you could uh avoid
this the pauses it might work better
hear that
so you see
the
one hack
with a
there
we're getting about I've been working
with what he's saying so this either
needs to doctor fixed or stopped is our
motion yeah your honored up let me just
try one last thing okay uh Dr Bain could
you stop your video and then just talk
once you've shown the formulas after
that way the signal might be clear
right I.T guy well
now
sorry Council but it doesn't sound like
it's going to work
phone phone would work yeah Dr Bain
Dr Bain
sir can you hear me
yes I didn't I
there can we call you on your phone and
uh because we're having technical
difficulties with the video and the
Roger that
should I call your cell number
uh
on the iPad
if that gives you
I don't see that I've got other numbers
for you can you
can I call your cell number well I guess
he's okay
foreign
what number should I call
six
can we put a time frame on this
I mean they know what their what their
time is that they have left so
you want me to FaceTime or what no uh
we're just going to do it by uh audio
yeah just uh you're you're live in court
that you can the jury can hear you
Roger that and so do you have my
equations up
are those equations
there they are
okay Dr babe
sir we've got your equations up
okay so do you have the one the sheet
where it starts off with x equals x zero
plus v 0 t and so on yes okay perfect
all right so
so as I was saying uh should I continue
sir yes please Roger that
so in order to make the equation work
you have to solve for time which is T
oh
would it make sense to uh to take your
next witness while someone is outside
trying to
re-establish
okay and your honor
seeing a potential I guess I could just
bring
while they're calling
I was prepared in Cross to maybe show Dr
Baines some documents or even draw some
things
um I don't I wasn't sure whether I'd get
into that but depending on what I hear I
was going to do that I know I don't have
a ton of time and maybe I decide not to
but this obviously makes it so I can't
do that which is a problem
parties are going to be hamstrung on
this
so why don't we take it as it comes
we lost you there
just look at the phones and see if we're
still connected but
in any event uh once you get the time
0.466 seconds that's the time
it takes to free fall from a specific
height X which is measured on Mr
Sanderson
which is three and a half feet to his
ribs
and then you substitute P into the
equation velocity
equals one half a t squared in this case
typically for 25
equation is V equals a t
now
the reason I put the one half in there
with the asterisk and keep in mind I've
been on this case for two years
and up until this point no one has ever
asked me why that asterisk is there with
the one half well
keep in mind that those equations are
for free fall events so if you're
suspended in the air by x three and a
half feet then you are dropped to the
ground that's the velocity that you
would get
however we know that Mr Sanderson is not
suspended in the air when he collides or
when he makes contact with Ms Paltrow
so he's actually standing on his ski so
he's standing upright
so when he falls to the ground it's not
a Free Falling event
and you can appreciate that because when
he falls over the speed of his feet that
hit the ground is zero whereas the
velocity of his head is certainly much
greater than the velocity at his feet
so you have to know which I took his
measurement in the office how high the
point of interest is which is his ribs
because that's what he fractured in the
Collision
so once you do that
you substitute
the one half at squared asterisk into
the and that turns out to be 2.29 meters
per second and you put that into the
impact formula
and then
you obtain
uh what the impact force is so the
equation should be written f i impact
Force equals one half times in
parentheses B sub T asterisk all squared
and then over D the distance through
which the energy is transferred from the
ground to his ribs which I measured in
the office so you have to know those
quantities and understand that this is
not a Free Falling event so that's the
that's the big difference here and once
you have the 2.29 meters per second and
you substitute that in
and you just use Mr sanderson's weight
as the mass in that equation
utilize that there is not enough impact
Force to fracture those ribs so there
has to be a mitigating circumstance I.E
something fell on top of him in addition
to him falling to the ground to cause
those ribs to fracture in an otherwise
penalty male and so when you do the
calculation the object
and typically to practice ribs on the
lateral side which is where he practices
ribs takes about 4 000 Newtons
thereabouts
plus or minus 400 newtons 4 000 Newtons
plus or minus 400 this is a fraction of
those ribs
and when you work backwards the mass
required to do that indicates that the
object that fell on Mr Sanderson passed
away at least 100 pounds
So based on what I know about this case
any human that weighs greater than a
hundred pounds falling on Mr Sanderson
onto his license fracturing those Reds
would qualify as a traumatic event from
an impact Force calculation standpoint
now
so once understand that then you start
to consider other possible scenarios as
to is there any other way you could have
fractured those ribs the only other way
it could have if you consider him
striking Miss Paltrow from behind
is that if you were to do that you would
have to generate a rotational Force
on him and Miss Paltrow
resulting in him falling on the ground
and Miss Paltrow falling on top of him
okay now keep in mind as I already
calculated maybe you look up there it
took less than half a second to fall to
the ground
and so for him to ski into Miss Patra
and then rotate 180 degrees to the
ground in less than a half a second
requires a rotation rate of greater than
400 Degrees per second
now
Olympic swimmer Olympic divers that is
when they do their twisted and turnings
on their competition Dives don't
generate any greater than 400 Degrees
per second on their dies and then when
you take into consideration
Newton's first and third laws
you know Miss Paltrow is certainly not
uh twisting and turning as she Struck
from behind so in order for her to
rotate around with Mr Sanderson
Mr Sanderson has to according to his
first and third laws grab her
and then take her to the ground in a
twisting fashion where she lands on top
of them now Olympic swimmers if they
were to grab a hundred pound 100 pound
weight or more and try to do those
rotations that's just not going to
happen because the center of gravity is
too far away from the moment or the
inertial point or rotation so that's
probably not going to happen unless
hypothesize
that this did in fact happen which is
highly unlikely
if this Paltrow landed on Mr Sanderson
and he landed on his back that means she
landed on his chest
and if that were to happen the Ritz
would not fracture on the lateral aspect
of his chest as we see in the medical
records so we know based on that and the
low probability of the rotational or the
angular velocity
that not happen so that only leaves one
possible scenario to satisfy Newtonian
physics
the uh of Mr sanderson's uh measurements
and his medical records and that means
that he was struck from behind
went down onto his right side making
contact with the ground with his elbow
the energy was transferred into his
wrist that fractured The Roots now
I would like to add that
had the risk fractures not occurred
no one will be able to do this analysis
period
and that's all I got to say about it
thank you that's all for me the defense
counsel question
prior to that
Mr Egan thanks your honor am I to talk
through this can you hear me Dr Bain
barely barely is this Mr Egan yes it's
Mr Egan
hi good morning Mr Egan
good morning
um
given the uh
limitations we have I'm not going to ask
you some things I prepared I can't show
you a number of things
um so this may this may take a second
um
less than we we planned here but let me
start this way
Dr sure you watch Dr shurs or read Dr
shears trial testimony right
and so you didn't see him writing up the
equations on the board for the jury And
discussing those for them
okay
but did you get a text picture of the
drawings that he he drew for the jury
and Dr
sure has significant experience applying
the principles of biomechanics to skiing
correct
uh to my knowledge he does I don't know
him personally or professionally
and and you do not have that kind of
experience correct
with regards to what sir applying the
principles of biomechanics to skiing
have not worked on skiing problems if
you will
um okay certainly and Dr sure has
studied the physics of skiing and ski
equipment correct
I understand Neo but primarily bindings
with skis
uh yeah I think it goes beyond that but
that's that's right and and you have not
you have not done such studies correct
no not on ski bindings and did you learn
anything from Dr sure's testimony given
his experience with ski
applying biomechanics to skiing and in
your lack of it did you learn anything
from him
heard anything I mean
a free fall event that's what I learned
primarily and that's why uh that face
basic assumption flaw is analysis
and you but that's the only thing you
learned
I'm sorry I didn't hear that and that's
the only thing you learned
yes that was uh basically uh the that's
why I'm here today
um do you know is this okay can you hear
me better if I do this absolutely
absolutely I just you know leaning in
front of the jury here no no I
appreciate that I can hear you really
good now five by five thanks yeah it's
yeah it's a first okay so uh do you know
anything about din settings those are
the settings that dictate when ski
bindings release
okay
right okay and you also that means you
wouldn't know how much force it would
have taken to release Mr sanderson's
Boots from his skis correct
not just that you didn't calculate it
you you don't even know what force it
would require is that right
okay
um
did you catch in Dr sure's testimony
that
he's read the
um
voluminous literature on rib fractures
and the biomechanics of rib fractures
uh
but uh we actually we did experiments in
the lab in the military doing that so
okay but my question was just did you
see did you see that part of her read
that part of his testimony
that's what he uh uh purchased okay and
it sounds like you you dispute his
reading of that literature
oh I don't I mean he portrays that he
knows a lot about uh biomechanics I
don't know I've never been in a
discussion with him to uh familiarize
myself with his level of knowledge in
that field
um
you said earlier that
part of Dr sure's
um
mistake in your mind is that he didn't
acknowledge that he didn't solve for T
is that what you said
well that's one of them okay so that we
just want to stay on that one for a
second
uh did did you did you objection let the
witness finish his answer Council
he answered my question I was just going
Mr Beam did you have anything else that
you needed to say to respond to the
previous answer
okay thanks Dr Bim I don't mean to
interrupt I'm just trying to be quick
because I don't have much time I
understand Mr Egan so did I mean I'm in
a hurry too I'm trying to make a
luncheon I got it yeah well we
appreciate you making time during your
vacation so
um did you miss in Dr sure's testimony
where he pointed to the pages in in your
equations where you solved fatigue and
he just assumed what you had done
he did an analysis or critique I might
add on my analysis I don't see where he
calculated it himself right he was just
working off yours just assuming what you
had done and then doing his own
calculations that is correct okay thanks
that's all the questions I have thanks
thank you Mr Egan appreciate it
Mr Bueller
Dr Bain
yes sir okay
uh
so you did see the calculations from Dr
sure
what he did which was critique my
analysis and that was it I don't know
what
I don't know if he did any calculations
based on what I saw in his testimony
if you could quickly focus in on what is
the error that you think Dr sure made
he did not consider Newton's person's
laws so that's a violation of classical
physics
and then second of all he assumed a free
fall
and we know that Mr Sanders and did not
free fall to the ground
because he was standing up and he fell
over
and it's the velocity when you hit the
group when you fall over is much less
that a free fall and we did those
studies at the
Naval under research laboratory because
we were interested in that research for
our military personnel so knowing what
because you can appreciate standing up
when you fall over the speed of your
feet is zero whereas the speed of your
head is something else and it's much
different than a free fall event
okay thank you that's all I have Council
uh
and uh am I allowed to leave over I have
one question James Egan has one more
question
oh thanks yeah thank you Lawrence I'm
back Dr Bain uh
that's great one last question do you
you're talking about Free Fall do you
recall the testimony for Mr Sanderson
that he went Airborne during the
accident
I don't recall that okay thank you
anything else just one question uh uh is
it possible for a doctor or for Terry
Sanderson to have gone Airborne when his
skis were on the snow
no uh no that's not gonna happen because
uh the the skier would have to go that
hit him from behind would have to be
going in excess of 50 or 60 miles an
hour which I think is highly unlikely
unless we're dealing with an Olympic ski
downhill skier here okay that's all I
have thank you Dr Bain no more questions
thank you
and uh your honor am I excused
yes you are thank you Mr Bain thank you
that's all we have no more witnesses
your honors so you rest your rebuttal
case
okay so you've now received all of the
evidence
okay
so you've now received all of the
evidence I just need to ask the lawyers
a couple questions and then we'll
proceed so could you approach the bench
please
okay members of the jury you have been
handed the closing jury instructions
there's one more document you'll get
before the parties argue but we're gonna
we're gonna give that to you right after
the break we'll I'm going to read
through these and then we'll take a
short break
so these are jury instructions 18 and 22
through 42 if you turn to page 2 and you
can make notes on these if you'd like so
page two is jury instruction number 18
which has already been read to you most
of it as modified because I did modify
it during the trial and I read it to you
during the trial as it stated right here
so now you've got the the complete 18
the modified 18. turning then to jury
instruction 22 which was also read to
you during the trial unlimited purpose
evidence
turning then to 23 a closing road map
members of the jury
you have now received all of the
evidence three things remain to be done
first I will give you additional
instructions that you will follow in
deciding this case
second the lawyers will give their
closing arguments the plaintiff will go
first then the defendant then the
plaintiff may give a rebuttal
finally you will go to the Jury Room to
decide the case
in the Jury Room you will have two main
duties as jurors first you will decide
from the evidence what the facts are you
may draw all reasonable inferences from
that evidence
second you will take the law I give you
in the instructions apply it to the
facts and reach a verdict
instruction 24 closing arguments when
the lawyers give their closing arguments
keep in mind that they are advocating
their views of the case
what they say during their closing
arguments is not evidence if the lawyers
say anything about the evidence that
conflicts with what you remember you are
to rely on your memory of the evidence
if they say anything about the law that
conflicts with these instructions you
are to rely on these instructions
council could you remove that easel it's
kind of blocking my view of the jury
number 25
you can just shove it over next to the
screen
legal rulings during the trial I have
made certain legal or certain rulings I
made those rulings based on the law and
not because I favor one side or the
other however if I sustained an
objection if I did not accept evidence
offered by one side or the other or if I
ordered that certain testimony be
stricken then you must not consider
those things in reaching your verdict
26 fault defined your goal as jurors is
to decide whether Terry Sanderson was
harmed
and if so whether anyone is at fault for
that harm
you must also decide whether Gwyneth
Paltrow was harmed and if so whether
anyone is at fault for that harm
if you decide that more than one person
is at fault you must then allocate fault
among them
fault means any wrongful act or failure
to act the wrongful act or failure to
act alleged in this case is negligence
your answers to the questions on the
verdict form will determine whether
anyone is at fault
we will review the verdict form in a few
minutes after your break
instruction 27 negligence defined you
must decide whether Gwyneth Paltrow or
Terry Sanderson was negligent or whether
they were both negligent
negligence means that a person did not
use reasonable care
we've all had a duty we all have a duty
to use reasonable care to avoid injuring
others
reasonable care is simply what a
reasonable careful person would do in a
similar situation
a person may be negligent in acting or
in failing to act
the amount of care that is reasonable
depends on the situation
ordinary circumstances do not require
extraordinary caution
but some situations require more care
because a reasonably careful person
would understand that more danger is
involved
to establish negligence Terry Sanderson
has the burden of proving that one
Gwyneth Paltrow was negligent and two
this negligent this negligence was a
cause of Terry Sanders harm
if you find that Gwyneth Paltrow was
negligent then you must determine
whether that negligence was a cause of
Terry sanderson's harm and whether Terry
Sanderson sustained damages
Gwyneth Paltrow claims that Terry
Sanderson was negligent in causing his
own harm
and that should read and in causing her
harm
to establish Terry sanderson's
negligence Gwyneth Paltrow has the
burden of proving
um
Gwyneth Paltrow has the burden of
proving that one Terry Sanderson was
negligent and two that this negligence
was a cause of Terry Sanders harm
and her own harm
I'll send in a corrected instruction 27.
if you find that Terry Sanderson was
negligent then you must determine
whether his negligence was a cause of
his own harm
and
uh and her own and Miss Paltrow's harm
and whether Paltrow sustained damages
construction 28 allocation of fault
if you decide that more than one person
is at fault you must decide each
person's percentage of of fault that
caused the harm
you determine what's suffered in this
case
this allocation must total 100 percent
Mr sanderson's Total Recovery will be
reduced by the percentage of fault that
you attribute to him
if you decide that this percentage is 50
or greater he will recover nothing
the same is true of Miss Paltrow's
recovery
when you answer the question on Damages
do not reduce the award by Mr
sanderson's or Miss Paltrow's
percentages I will calculate that later
instruction 29 violation of a safety law
violation of a safety law is evidence of
negligence
Terry Sanderson claims that Gwyneth
Paltrow violated Parts A and B of the
following safety law and Gwyneth Paltrow
claims that Terry Sanderson violated
part A of the following safety law
this is Summit County ordinance section
5-2-3 Reckless skiing
a reckless skiing prohibited no person
shall ski in a reckless or negligent
manner so as to endanger the life limb
or property of any person
B skier's duty to Injured party in the
event of collision
any skier involved in a collision
resulting in injury to any person shall
immediately stop at the scene of such
collision and render to such person
injured in such Collision reasonable
assistance
including the caring or the making of
arrangements for the caring of such
person by a physician surgeon or
hospital for medical or surgical
treatment if it is apparent that such
treatment is necessary or if such caring
is requested by the injured party
if you decide that Mr Sanderson and or
Miss Paltrow violated the safety law you
may consider the violation as evidence
of negligence
if you decide that Mr Sanderson and or
Miss Paltrow did not violate the safety
law you must disregard the violation
disregard the safety law
and decide whether they acted with
reasonable care under the circumstances
jury instruction 30 I've already
determined that Gwyneth Paltrow did not
leave the scene of the accident without
giving her contact information
during section 31 spoliation
Miss Paltrow has presented evidence that
a GoPro video of the ski Collision may
have existed
Sanderson asserts that the GoPro video
of the ski Collision never existed
if you find that one a GoPro video of
the Collision likely existed
and two that any such GoPro video was in
The Possession or control of Sanderson
and three pla that the plaintiff
intentionally or negligently disposed of
or lost the GoPro video of the Collision
or otherwise failed to offer a
reasonable excuse for failing to
preserve the GoPro video of the
Collision before defendant had an
opportunity to review and evaluate it
then you may but are not required to
conclude that the evidence would have
been unfavorable to Sanderson
construction 32 introduction to tort
damages economic and non-economic
damages introduced I will now instruct
you about damages
my instructions are given as a guide for
calculating what damages should be if
you find that either Terry Sanderson or
Gwyneth Paltrow is entitled to them
however if you decide no one is entitled
to recover damages then you must
disregard these instructions
if you decide that Miss Paltrow's fault
caused Mr Henderson's Mr sanderson's
harm you must decide how much money will
fairly encompensate him for that harm
if you decide that Mr sanderson's fault
cause Miss Paltrow's harm then you may
award Miss Paltrow one dollar which is
the maximum amount she seeks
there are two kinds of Damages economic
and non-economic I would explain the
difference between them
33 proof of damages
to be entitled to damages the party must
prove two points first that damages
occurred
there must be a reasonable probability
not just speculation that is
party
suffered damages from the other party's
fault
second the amount of Damages the level
of evidence required to prove the amount
of Damages is not as high as what is
required to prove the occurrence of
Damages there must still be evidence not
just speculation that gives a reasonable
estimate of the amount of Damages but
the law does not require a mathematical
certainty
in other words if a party has proved
that they have been damaged
and they have established a reasonable
estimate of those damages the other
party may not Escape liability because
of some uncertainty in the amount of
damages
34 economic damage is defined
economic damages are the amount of money
that will fairly and adequately
compensate a party for measurable losses
of money or property caused by another
party's fault
Mr Sanderson is not claiming any
economic damages
therefore you should not award Mr
Sanderson any economic damages
Miss Paltrow is seeking one dollar in
economic damages
35 non-economic damage is defined Mr
Sanderson is seeking non-economic
damages
non-economic damages are the amount of
money that will fairly and adequately
compensate Mr Sanderson for losses other
than economic losses
non-economic damages are not capable of
being exactly measured
and there is no fixed rule standard or
formula for them
non-economic damage may still be awarded
even though they may be difficult to
compute
it is your duty to make this
determination with calm and reasonable
judgment the law does not require the
testimony of any witness to establish
the amount of non-economic damages
in awarding non-economic Damages among
the things that you may consider are one
the nature and extent of injuries
two the pain and suffering both mental
and physical
three the extent to which Mr Sanderson
has been prevented from pursuing his
ordinary affairs
for the degree and character of any
disfigurement five the extent to which
Mr Sanderson has been Limited in the
enjoyment of life
and six whether the consequences of
these injuries are likely continue to
continue and for how long
while you may not award damages based on
speculation the law requires only that
the evidence provide a reasonable basis
for assessing the damages but does not
require a mathematical certainty
I will now instruct you on particular
items of Economic and non-economic
damages presented in this case
instruction 36 pre-existing conditions
Terry Sanderson is alleged to have had
physical emotional or mental conditions
before the time of the ski Collision
he is not entitled to recover damages
for those conditions
however he is entitled to recover
damages for any for any aggravation of
the conditions caused by Gwyneth
Paltrow's fault even if those conditions
made him more vulnerable to physical or
emotional harm than the average person
this is true even if another person may
not have suffered any harm from the
event at all
Gwyneth Paltrow has the burden to prove
what portion of the alleged harm is the
result of pre-existing conditions
if you are unable to make such an
apportionment then you must conclude
that all damages if any you find were
suffered by Mr Sanders suffered by Mr
Sanderson were caused by Miss Paltrow
Mitigation Of damages
each party had a duty to exercise
reasonable diligence and ordinary care
to minimize the damages caused by the
other's fault
any damages award should not include
those that could have been avoided by
taking reasonable steps
Terry Sanderson has the burden to prove
that Gwyneth Paltrow could have
minimized her damages but failed to do
so
Gwyneth Paltrow has the burden to prove
that Terry Sanderson could have
minimized his damages but failed to do
so
if a party made reasonable efforts to
minimize damages then your award to that
party should include the amounts that he
or she reasonably incurred to minimize
them
your honor my memory is that jury
instruction 38 was stricken by both
parties yesterday okay
I actually it wasn't it was not it was
not straightened I apologize please
proceed okay 38 collateral Source
payments
you shall award damages in an amount
that fully compensates Terry Sanderson
do not speculate on or consider any
other possible sources of benefit Terry
Sanderson may have received after you
have received your verdict I will make
whatever adjustments may be appropriate
39.
four-person selection and duties and
jury deliberations
among the first things you should do
when you go to the Jury Room to
deliberate is to appoint someone to
serve as the jury for a person
four persons should not dominate the
jury's discussion but rather should
facilitate the discussion of the
evidence and make sure that all members
of the jury get the chance to speak
the four persons opinions should be
given the same weight as those of other
members of the jury
once the jury has reached a verdict the
four person is responsible for filling
out and signing the verdict form on
behalf of the entire jury
in the Jury Room discuss the evidence
and speak your minds with each other
open discussion should help you reach an
agreement on a verdict
listen carefully and respectfully to
each other's views and keep an open mind
about what others have to say
I recommend that you not commit yourself
to a particular verdict before
discussing all the evidence
try to reach an agreement but only if
you can do so honestly and in good
conscience
if there is a difference of opinion
about the evidence or the verdict do not
hesitate to change your mind if you
become convinced that your position is
wrong
on the other hand do not give up your
honestly held views about the evidence
simply to agree on a verdict
to give in to pressure from other jurors
or just to get the case over with
in the end your vote must be your own
in reaching your verdict you may not use
methods of chance such as drawing straws
or flipping a coin
the verdict must reflect your individual
careful and conscientious judgment
instruction 40 do not resort to chance
when you deliberate do not flip a coin
draw straws choose opinions at random or
use other methods of chance
instead you must weigh the evidence
carefully and come to a decision that is
supported by the evidence
if you decide that a party is entitled
to recover damages you must then agree
upon the amount of money to award that
party
each of you should State your own
independent judgment on what the amount
should be
you must thoughtfully consider the
amount suggested
evaluate them according to these
instructions and the evidence and reach
an agreement on the amount
you must not agree in advance to average
the estimates
instruction 41 agreement on special
verdict
after the break I'm going to give you a
form called the special verdict that
contains several questions and
instructions you must answer the
questions based on the instructions and
the evidence that you have seen and
heard during this trial
because this is not a criminal case your
verdict does not have to be unanimous
at least six jurors must agree on the
answer to each question
but they do not have to be the same six
jurors on each question
as soon as six or more of you agree on
the answer to all of the required
questions the four persons should sign
and date the verdict form and tell the
bailiff that you have finished the
bailiff will escort you back to this
courtroom you should bring the completed
special verdict form with you
and then jury instruction 42 I'll read
to you at the end of the trial
so that that completes these
instructions
I wonder if you could write your names
on on the top of that
because as you noticed I did make some
changes to a few of the instructions as
we went along and it I'll have the
bailiff insert the new and take out the
old if you could do that the new
instructions before they're given back
to you
yes
pardon me
on the verdict form the four person will
write their number and their name uh on
the on when they sign it and there's
only be one signature on it which would
be the four person
and when I select the two jurors that
will unfortunately have to leave us
before deliberations I'll just I'll just
tell you your Journal number I won't say
your name and I'll give you further
instructions about those two individuals
so I'll do that in a few minutes after
all the after all the arguments are
completed
so
we'll at this time we'll take a recess
and thank you
jury
defendants no I would like to get a hard
copy of the special bird form just so I
can read it one more time we've got some
issues with the verdict form I wonder if
you could come into Chambers if we could
kind of go through that
thank you and then the
kid can Peter Jensen have the defense
binder index and certainly one of the
plaintiff's lawyers is welcome to be
present
to do the final swap out with the new
index he's not adding one thing he's is
that something we need to do before
closings
no no
he could do it at the moment there there
are discharged to delivery normally um
sure well if you want to get those those
into evidence I suggest you try as soon
as possible
well I do move to admit the new index
all those documents on the new index
which they have any objection
objections to the index to defend his
trial exhibits no all of the exhibits
being received so that's on the new
index and now he just needs to make the
changes including blacking out Mr
sanderson's uh contact information
contact information social security
birth date
address is the one that's most common
yeah okay yeah all right so take a quick
break and then have the balance bring
you back to my Chambers on a special
verdict for him thank you
thank you
ready for the jury
foreign
okay you should have on your chair a
document three pages called special
verdict form I'm going to go through
that right now
members of the jury please answer the
following questions in the order that
they are presented
if you find that the issue has been
proved by a preponderance of the
evidence answer yes if not no at least
six jurors must agree on the answer to
all of the required questions but they
need not be the same six on each
question
when six or more of you have agreed on
the answer to each question that is
required to be answered your four
persons should sign and date the form
and advise the bailiff that you have
reached a verdict
Gwyneth Paltrow question one was Gwyneth
Paltrow at fault yes or no if you answer
yes go to question two if you answer no
go to question three below
question number two was Gwyneth
Paltrow's fault a cause of Terry
sanderson's harm yes or no regardless of
your answer go to question three
Terry Sanderson question three was Terry
Sanderson at fault if you answer yes or
no if you answer yes go to question four
if you answer no go to question five
below
four was Terry sanderson's fault a cause
of Gwyneth Paltrow's harm yes or no
regardless of your answer go to Number
Five Below number five if your answers
to question one and three are both no
you should not proceed further except to
date and sign this verdict form and
return it to the courtroom otherwise
continue to question six
imperative fault question 6 Gwyneth
Paltrow what percentage of the fault do
you assign to Gwyneth Paltrow
if your answer to either questions one
or two is no then enter zero percent
and there's a blank and a place for you
to put your number in proceed to
question seven question seven Terry
Sanderson what percentage of the fault
do you assign to Terry Sanderson
and there's a blank and a place for you
to put your percentage in if you and if
your answer to either questions three or
four is no then enter zero the total
must equal 100 percent
if Terry sanderson's fault is less than
50 percent answer question eight
do not deduct from the damages any
percentage of fault that you have
assessed to Terry Sanderson the judge
will make any necessary deductions later
if Terry sanderson's fault is fifty
percent or more do not answer question
eight and proceed to question nine
damages Terry Sanderson question eight
what amount fairly compensates Terry
Sanderson for non-economic damages
dollar sign blank
damages Gwyneth Paltrow number nine what
amount fairly compensates Gwyneth
Paltrow for economic damages this cannot
exceed one dollar dollar sign blank
when six or more of you have agreed on
the answer to each question that is
required to be answered your four-person
should sign and date the form and advise
the bailiff that you have reached a
verdict
so we're we'll now hear from the lawyers
with their closing arguments plaintiff
will go first
we'll check with the with the expert
here
hello
ladies and gentlemen a jury thank you
for your attentiveness
during these two weeks it's been a hard
long case
I've tried a lot of cases in my lifetime
this has been a hard long Case by the
way it's about an hour each way
going to Salt Lake with traffic so that
adds to it
but you've been very attentive I I've
seen
taking notes and paying attention
no one nodded off
so thank you again
now
turn on my
Lawrence and I are going to split this
by the way I apologize for my code
I can't really choose when those come
I've got asthma and it makes it worse
but I've done everything I can to try to
resolve it took all the tasks I'm
negative for coven Etc but I still
always pregnant so I apologize for the
coffee
really three issues in the case
number one
who hit whom
okay
number two
that it caused any damage
number three
what are other damages
no damages
now
Gwyneth Paltrow
in this case
is not a liar Terry Sanderson is not a
liar
okay
uh Gwyneth is a good person okay
she's a good mother
and she loves her children and she's
passionate about many things now we
don't usually say good things about
other people in our closing but I think
that's an accurate statement
I think that she believes
and I believe Gwyneth Paltrow
and she says she believes
she says Terry hit me in the van
and she believes it it's a sincere
belief
she's not a liar because of
it pardon me but the problem is
a sincere belief doesn't make it so you
know
some of you are scarce and some of you
aren't okay
pardon me when you're involved in a ski
crash
uh it can be very confusing I don't care
who hit whom
it can be very confusing
so I think she sincerely believes that
she got hit in the back
the problem is
you have to make a decision
based on the evidence that you've heard
here
okay I don't have any evidence
now
um
let me tell you to illustrate this
about something that happened to me
about a year and a half ago
we live in downtown Salt Lake
and we use that Costco or shop it at
Costco
on 17 South and third West some of you
are probably wondering largest one in
the world okay we are having a hard time
for that is it on your chest yeah maybe
it's not turned on oh
it says on I know I mean I'm picking it
up just fine on for the record but no
one else
or maybe put it higher
foreign
I just got gas at Costco it was about
July of 2022
uh no 2021
and uh I was at intersection this is
pretty busy intersection
there are two lanes North and South two
lanes East and West two each
and there's a left-hand turnling
I had a red light
and I was the first one at the
intersection got a good look at it
I looked in my rear view mirror on my
left side
and there are there's a green
arrow for each Direction going east and
west turning South and turning North
understand that
so uh I'm waiting to have a red light
and there's a lady across the way from
me
car heading west for turning South
she had a green arrow like I saw one uh
heading north
I looked in my mirror and here comes a
guy at about 40 45 miles an hour on the
inside Lane
of 17 South
I said my goodness
he's going to hit that woman
he's making that turn and sure enough
smack her and smacked her hard
okay didn't slow down at all
well I was had a good view of it and the
car Spider-Man but I was able to get by
there's a Maverick
on the uh the southeast corner of the
intersection
I pulled in there
ran to her car
and ask her are you okay
like everybody does she said yeah I
think so
I didn't think she was looking at her
but she said she was okay
okay so I ran ran over to the other guy
I was the first one there some people
were beginning to stop
and the guy that ran the the red light
said are you okay
he said yeah I think so I said Well
why'd you run the red light
you know what his answer was I didn't it
was Green
well I wasn't going to sit there and
argue with a guy like that or those
circumstances
but he said it was Green
so when the police came a few minutes a
couple minutes later
uh and you got to be careful as an
attorney I gave them my card not to get
the case you know I can't do that
unethical but let people know who I was
they could call me get a cop a card and
I gave each of the persons a card
in about several months later I guess so
I couldn't call some insurance adjusters
want me to tell what happened
and I tell you that story because
so often
people that are in these types of events
have a totally different viewpoint
so we don't hold anything against
Gwyneth for her viewpoint it's sincerely
expressed but she's wrong
based on the evidence
okay
and Terry is correct no
what's the evidence that Gwyneth hit
Terry
number one and there's no particular
order on this but
Terry's a strong skier Advanced
intermediate
Mr Christensen said he saw him going
down the hill doing wide radius turns
that's side to side all the way back and
forth
now on a beginner's run
that's highly unlikely for an advanced
spear you don't do that
you don't do that
too many people
uh and so that doesn't make sense
number two
I'll call it the scream heard around the
world okay this is being broadcast
everywhere whether it's on court TV
I'm getting emails every day
Canada Great Britain
uh
there's a loud screen
Terry heard it
the loud screen
uh Craig Ramon heard it and looked over
several other people heard it Carrie
Oaks said she heard it
in a Christian Center Constant to look
over
it's before the impact
and um you don't
if you're the downhill skier
like Gwyneth claimed she was
you don't scream at something you can't
see
you don't
that's the uh uphill skier that's going
to make that screen
and that was Gwyneth Paltrow
distraction
everybody here
probably been apparent most of you not
some of you maybe
uh but I've had my kids up there and
they want me to watch them ski uh
and Mommy Mommy wants to see a karaoke
said that and that the deposition
segment that you read said that three
times
and uh
that's important can we show glitter's
that position up here
John what are we talking about here Mr
Sykes is this deposition testimony that
was read into court yes and is it only
deposition testimony okay
deposition meaning trial testimony well
it was read in the court
may we approach her honor sure
foreign
[Music]
you can make the screen only show the
part that was actually ready or is that
that okay judge like that that looks
good okay
now miss Paltrow isn't it true
is that true I'm just a country lawyer
here okay isn't it true
okay that your kids wanted to watch you
ski or pardon me that the kids wanted
you to watch them ski isn't that true
Vegas of time I can still watch my
children ski and we ski directly into my
back by someone okay which is what
happened and I'm going to admit Mr
Owen's statement and my own and here's
how it reads
isn't it true that your kids want to
watch you ski
or pardon me that the kids want you to
watch them ski
I can still watch my children ski and be
skied directly into my back by someone
which is what happened
now
is my witness
and uh Craig Ramon we were thought about
having him testify again today about
those drawings but we decided not to do
it
but
he saw the whole thing he saw the impact
uh and he is the only one that saw
that's a key piece of evidence now who
is Craig limone
he's an acquaintance Terry
it's part of a meet-up group
it's not close to Terry
they went to get garlic Burgers twice
okay
he has no dog in the fight ladies and
gentlemen no dog in the fight
he's an he's independently wealthy you
can tell that by what he does your honor
that's as soon as facts not inevitable
well there's just a minute
objection overruled the jury will have
to recall what the evidence was and this
is
all this business I don't know 10 years
ago and all he does now is ski and
travel and scuba dive okay
uh he has no reason
no motive to falsify this okay
uh confirmation that was Meetup emails
that you saw
uh
that was one of the last evidence I
think it was 44 was it I won't go over
it with you
but we printed that out I think Saturday
or Monday
it gives you the number of days since it
was entered
and you add those up you go right back
to February
26 27 28th around there
a strong evidence
Terry has repeatedly said to his medical
providers that he was hit in the back
over a period of years
and that he has problems medical
problems for them
the broken ribs that's that's one of the
strongest pieces of evidence you have
that Terry was the guy that was hit he
was the downhill skier okay
four broken ribs two of them separated
like that
work together
and that's uh very serious it's very
painful
but the pattern of those broken ribs
two MDS one from Utah and Dr Bain so
that pattern of broken ribs supports
parts
the fact that he was hit from behind now
I'm not going to go into all the details
of that that's what he said
um
and Dr beam who just testified again
today
said that Dr sure was simply wrong in
his philosophy he or his formula he
assumed it was a free fall and it wasn't
a free fall
broken ribs
how do you get that without a
significant impact now
uh the flaky Deer Valley investigation
I think suggests a cover-up
Eric Christensen I think was
unbelievable and inconsistent
uh
and there were a number of things I'm
not going to go over each one of them
but I will talk about one the claim that
Terry said he was okay now some of you
have probably had broken ribs or loved
ones that have had them you know
even uh Steve Grant up here said it's
extremely painful
now this whole process took place
between 11 55 which is the time of grass
incident report
and 1202 when
Ramon flagged down the ski patrol and
1204 when Whitney Smith arrived so we're
talking about
about uh seven to nine minutes
okay and they would have you believe
that a man with four broken ribs four
two separated
told not only Eric Christensen that he
was okay but two other unnamed
unidentified ski patrollers had never
logged it in he told them he was okay
now that's just unbelievable that that
would happen to a person with four
broken ribs not just one but four
Steve between the legs
I don't know how many of you are skiers
I don't remember you said it here in
your interviews
three weeks ago but uh
to have someone ski between your legs
she thought it was a sexual assault
okay
but to have someone with both skis
that someone is moving and shushing back
and forth
it's just another unbelievable claim
that can't happen
now
um
and then why not squeeze away to lunch
uh
the only way
that Terry Sanderson knew that this is
what it's called
as Christensen got angry and said your
buddy just took out Gwyneth Paltrow
which is an odd comment to make
like
just took out a person
you know but he had to put in Gwyneth
Paltrow that's the only way we know that
that's why you're here
now
all right conversation
this event caused
an injury
well I've already mentioned this the
impact was significant enough to break
four ribs
you know the impact in the fall that is
a significant impact
on the location the right front
is where you would expect it under the
circumstances
uh
loss of consciousness
it was only a few minutes maybe maybe
two maybe three
but there was a loss of consciousness
widely reported in the medical records
and that day
why did it work uh
I'd mentioned the okay
uh
I want to mention that again so
it was significant enough
at the time
the very first thing that anybody
noticed
was that was that Terry forgot how to
ski he was snowplow went down the hill
and advanced intermediate snow plowing
down the hill
think about that for a minute you know
uh and Craig Ramon says hey Terry you
forgot how to ski and that's when Craig
Ramon said I gotta flag somewhere down
so he did and he told that person
he's got a head injury that's the words
he used the head injury
now uh it took him
five seconds
and Craig acted it out up here uh five
seconds to be able
to tell him his name
he didn't know where he was at first
that's a significant impact that's a
concussion
now
uh
just keep a troll flag down at 1202
Whitney Smith arrives
what a sweet person
and Terry's taken off the hill and it's
aboggan
now you know
that's no fun but it shows you something
happened
uh she writes disoriented rib pain
by the way Elena Fung who treats
thousands and thousands and thousands of
TBI victims set loss of consciousness is
not required
okay not be quiet
uh
headache and that that day uh I think at
the clinic in Park City dullness in the
front of the head
and Whitney Smith said go to the ER
and Dr McMahon said go to the ER so the
next several months you have new
symptoms of TBI
that show up in the VA records cognitive
personality social and emotional
I could go through and show them to you
but you you all saw them but then
one of the most significant
pieces of evidence here
is a sudden and precipitous change
in Terry Sanderson
sudden and precipitous okay now I'm not
talking about when he came home and
Carlene you know
said he didn't want to be touched he's
got four broken ribs
but Carlene who loved him said it was a
love relationship
she wanted to marry him
they have been together 300 days a year
up here and then down there in St George
for about a year and a half
it's a long time to look at someone
he loved him she traveled with him she
wanted to marry him and you saw how she
choked up
when she
explained how the relationship ended
that he changed his personality changed
polygression Shea Harris
same thing big changes they didn't see
him as often
so that's sudden and precipitous change
is a sign of brain Israel
diagnosis of concussion the VA diagnosed
it multiple Physicians diagnosed all the
defense experts submitted it everyone
had admitted it they minimized the
Exterminator but they all admitted he
had a concussion every one of them
everyone
uh
uh Dr Gabby Dr Fong Dr Goldstein Dr King
the only question was severity in
permanency but every one of them
they didn't want to admit it but they
gave different numbers between 5 and 20
percent
of people that get a concussion it's
permanent
they have permanent problems
five and twenty percent doing that Dr
Fong thinks it's higher than that even
uh
now
the physics
Dr beam explained the physics I think
second day of trial and a little bit
today but he's a neurologist but he's
also a biomedical engineer that's
different than Dr sure he's a
biomechanical engineer but Dr Payne
specializes in how Force affects the
body
very highly respected in that field
that's very rare not very many of them
um Terry talked about the loss of
friendships Mark Horan good example they
were good buddies when skiing
and they didn't like him anymore talked
about it
the the woman
that he was
going to Europe with
I don't remember her name you remember
it but
she changed her mind at the last minute
and had an NPC that's how Jenny got to
go
the experience of the his granddaughter
carrying into her
for how to tie a knot
big changes
Craig Ramon said Terry after the
accident it seemed like he could talk to
the wall for an hour and have a good
conversation
um faking
um
every witness you heard from
embedded in his tests
to find that
no no evidence of that at all
and by the way the VA records continue
up until the present day
and they didn't show you any single VA
record or that was ever suggested of
this man
uh mph
they suggested you know that could just
the uh
uh normative what is it called again
North normal pressure hydrocephalus
uh
he's got it but no symptoms
and it didn't change over about a
13-year period
uh
2009 to 2021
dementia they kind of implied that maybe
he's got that but when when we Corner
them on cross-examination not a one of
them said he had to mention and there's
no reference and he's fast the page the
records any diagnosis
um
degradation degradation
of Imaging okay we have Imaging I think
from 2009 to 2021
and all the defense experts plus our own
said there's no degradation
on these Imaging he hasn't he's got
white matter abnormalities probably half
of us do nothing
shout in there
no problems
no increase
you heard that just as recently as
yesterday
uh
now
I'm going to say just a few more things
here
in terms of time over to my colleague
Lawrence Bueller this is actually his
case he asked me to help
um
that day when Terry left his home
the ghost communion Deer Valley
Meetup Group
February 26 2016.
he anticipated like many many other days
in his life
a fun day of skiing
okay
and uh
he he never returned home that night
as the same Terry he never came home
figured to be speaking
Terry has tried to get off that mountain
but he's really still there
part of Terry will forever be on the
bandana run figuratively
uh
people who
are just after money and that was
suggested it's just after money and fame
somehow going through all of this and
spending all the money he spent on the
experts you know he's doing it for fame
give me a break
but
he spent hours and hours trying to get
better if you hurt anything
about him
he he is almost
a good word extreme and trying to get
better he does everything he can to get
better
um
anyway uh we hope
that you will help bring Terry home off
that mountain with a fair verdict today
now before I turn it over to Morris
I want to say one more thing about
executive function
okay
I had an experience up here that taught
me about that
40 years ago I was in the legislature
with a guy named Glenn Brown I think
he's still alive
he's in Colville has a dairy farm or
dead
and I said kidding about milking cows
you know so he invited me up to his farm
young lawyer
gonna show me how to how to milk house
never done it
got up there
and he showed me around his barn it was
really sophisticated for 40 years ago I
mean it's probably better now
but uh
when you think about why Terry never
came home think about this story and
then check your functions
because
he put a little stool out there for me
and I I sat down in my jeans and tried
to milk a candle by hand
it's very hard to do for a
country boy like me
they grew up in the city
but
I was able to squeeze out a little bit
of milk you know he gave me some to take
home
but I asked him about this situation I
said how do you do all this
you showed me this very sophisticated
uh situation
that milks cows automatically that's
automatically
it says without this Bob I could never
make it
couldn't do it can't get enough people
to come help me do it by hand like my
grandfather did
um
that's executive function that's what it
does for us we're able to do a lot of
things in life
and that milking mechanism was executive
function
for Glenn Brown's Farm
to produce milk now
this is one of Terry's status problems
his loss of executive functions okay
he cannot organize
and manipulate his life
to do things like he used to do it's the
saddest thing
and that's why part of him is still up
there on that mountain
thank you Lawrence
[Music]
that's my
said listen in
foreign
still good morning good morning everyone
oh
yeah
I had to go testing testing testing
I'm actually just hearing it right right
there just
please let's change the batteries
foreign
this case is simple
you've heard the first two parts of this
did this who hid whom
and if what are the damage that were
caused to Tarry
uh
and then
the next question is
how much are those damages
that's the part of the case I'll deal
with
this case is is about answering the
simple questions the law asks us
put on the form that we call the verdict
form which you'll get in a few minutes
or maybe this afternoon
verdict
that's an interesting word
it comes from Latin it's actually two
words
varus truth
or dicta
or to tell or told so combine it means
truth told
and that's what you're here for is the
so
what is the law
want us to tell the truth about
well let's look at what the verdict form
says
the first question is
was Gwyneth Paltrow at fault
as my colleague Bob Sykes said
the evidence is clear
there were four broken ribs
an eyewitness
there's lots of other evidence too
circumstantial evidence that Miss
Paltrow hit Terry Sanderson on February
26 2016.
stories have been consistent for seven
years
so the first question
we answer yes
now
earlier it was in jury instruction
number 27 the judge defined what
negligence is
and judges around the country have a
hard time defining what it is it's very
abstract very abstract
and what it means basically is
they knew it was dangerous to ski while
distracted
they knew that someone could get hurt if
they continue to do that
and they did it anyway
did they know the damage would be this
serious well
we've all heard about collisions
collisions happen on the football field
collisions happen even on sidewalks
sometimes people get
concussions
and Terry there's no doubt suffered a
concussion
but Terry's damage is not just a
concussion that goes away in a few
minutes or a few days or a couple weeks
you know that Terry's damages or his
concussion persisted for more than a
year and a half and that's been verified
by Dr Fong
Dr Gibby
Dr Goldstein and Dr Bain
even the defense's experts admit that he
had a concussion they quibble on how
long it's lasted but none of those
defense Witnesses actually examined
Terry
and as Bob pointed out none of them
really
acknowledged that Terry had problems one
of them refused to acknowledge the
before and after Witnesses
his two daughters
actually three but two daughters that
testified in this trial Shea and Paulie
his uh friend Mark harath
uh finally or the first witness after
Craig Ramon
was Carlene Davidson his ex-girlfriend
they'd known each other for 18 months
before the crash
six months after the crash
she testified that the damage continued
thus making it a permanent
um
permanent
this is a tongue twister
persistent concussive symptom
not permanent persistent concussive
syndrome is the long-term brain damage
that we're talking about so what it
means is every waking hour that Terry
has he's got this
brain injury that causes the so many
problems for him from executive function
to just
being able to deal with people
and as those Witnesses showed
Terry has a problem he looks fine it's
an invisible injury people know you know
that's what they say about brain injury
it's an invisible injury you
you see someone with a brain injury and
they look fine what's wrong with them if
he has a brain injury why isn't he in
bed and moping around and not doing
anything well that's the opposite of
Terry
it well it took a
while the crash took much of what he had
and left it on the mountain Terry still
has that drive to get better
and even though persistent concussive
symptoms are permanent
they last a lifetime they last forever
so 16 hours a day Terry is
dealing with his injury such that
as Bob mentioned
people get to know him
they after a while they don't want to
deal with them anymore
I'm sorry I have to say this but you
know I've known Terry now six years this
is just argument but it's
it's real
now the four broken ribs those are
painful for maybe three months or so
and the but the brain injury has
persisted
to this day and will last until he dies
the executive function the social
abilities the uh
the mental problems
driving to the store not having not
knowing where you are and having to use
GPS just to get home
these are real injuries that uh
Harry who is uh a very bright person you
would not know it just on talking to him
for 10 minutes
but once you get to know him better you
you realize he's got these problems that
just change everything it's
so as I talked to someone someone left
me a message
and every time I hear this voice message
it just makes me cry
uh
just because it's so just kind of flat
but he says
you know this person suffered a similar
injury 30 years ago
a persistent concussive syndrome or
injury brain a permanent brain injury
and she said
it's permanent
your personality changes permanent
and you lose everybody who knows you you
lose everybody
yeah your family they'll put up with you
and maybe the lawyers but really they're
just putting up with you
so let's go to the next question
well I'm going to go through uh
because this is a complicated case Miss
Paltrow is suing for one dollar
we're going to
go through these next questions
was Terry Sanderson at fault
Terry was hit from behind Craig Ramon
sod
rib injuries show it
now Dr share
for the defense
who's not a medical doctor
he's a mechanical engineer deals with
ski bindings mostly he says that Terry
Sanderson
likely
skirted under Gwyneth Paltrow and
somehow twisted around and broke his
ribs
and the as Dr Bain
confirmed again today that's all that's
impossible it defies the law of physics
so
I think you have to answer no
I mean it's a clear no
it was Terry Sanderson at fault number
three no
so then you skip to go to Five Below
and since one is yes
this is like a puzzle
Market
yeah I got a pen
I've got one
so was Terry Sanderson at fault I'll go
back to the first page
Gwyneth Paltrow at fault yes
oh
I forgot to do number two and you have
to go in order was Miss Paltrow's fault
cause of Terry sanderson's harm it
clearly is Terry Anderson was hit from
behind there was a scream and he was hit
from behind so the answer is yes so then
we go to three
because we answer number three no we
skip to five
if your answers to one and three are
both no you should not proceed well we
got a yes two yeses
otherwise continue to question six
Gwyneth Paltrow what percent of fault do
you assign to Gwyneth Paltrow if your
answer to either one or two is no
then enter zero
and to be honest with you this is the
first time I've seen the form because it
was just finalized just before we
started the old so I have to think about
this one a little bit but let's think
about it together
um
number uh what percent of fault do you
assign to Gwyneth Paltrow if your answer
either one or two is no then enter zero
well both are yes
so we have to
because Terry Sanderson did not cause
this crash you can't cause a crash when
you're hit from behind
what percent of fault do you assign to
Terry Sanderson well it has to add up to
100 so you have to
put in zero there
if Terry sanderson's fault is less than
50 percent
answer question eight
well it is so we skipped eight
what amount fairly compensates Terry
Sanderson for non-economic damages
non-economic damages
our time on Earth
is the most valuable time we have
that we know of at least in this
existence our time on Earth is one of
the most valuable things there are
there are paintings on a wall that are
worth 50 100 million dollars
there are houses
in these mountainsides they're worth
5 10 20 much more millions of dollars
there's even race horses that are worth
tens of millions of dollars well Terry's
none of those
Terry's in the last days of his life
probably has at least 10 years left
according to
what a lot of people think he's a he
guards his health he doesn't smoke he's
he's trying to pursue
a healthy lifestyle every single day
yeah he goes to the doctor
but
so he's since the crash it's been seven
years
and
let's say another 10 years
every single day he's got a 16 hours of
dealing with this brain injury
it's persistent concussive symptom
that causes all these problems
so how do we calculate that
as the instruction says for non-economic
damages jury instruction 35 which you
all have
it gives a detailed instruction about
that pain suffering loss of enjoyment of
life
and a retired person well-to-do person
like Terry who worked all his life
these are these Golden Years these are
the most valuable years when you can
enjoy your retirement and actually do
things like travel
but now he has to travel with other
people or he gets lost Dr Fong and his
other therapist all most of his
therapists have said
what's the best way to deal with
your brain injury well do the things
that make you happy be active he could
sit around and mope around and be an
obvious brain injury victim but no Terry
doesn't want to be brain injured he
wants to live life to its fullest
so
16 hours a day
he's got this
issue
that
where a big part of them was left up on
that bandana ski run
oh
so you have the power here this is
before we were just
arguing and presenting evidence and the
judge was really on it but now the judge
is going to pass the case to you
and this is where you decide what
happens next
so I'm going to suggest I'm not going to
ask this is not a
Terry asked me several years ago when I
first learned of his case well what do
you think it's worth
I said well Terry could you if you could
turn the Earth backwards like Superman
he says I'd rather go back in time and
never have this
so how do we calculate this
well I'm going to suggest a number
uh account this is just a suggestion
that we do it with 16 hours a day
about the formulas Dr bam and Dr sure
give you a lot of formulas but hopefully
these will be simpler or simpler than
all those so that's 16 hours a day
year
then the next question is
the years well it's been seven years
since the crash
Terry's likely to live
another 10 years probably we hope longer
much longer he wants to live at 130.
but
at least 10 years
so seven years since the crash 10 years
that's 17 years
so we're going to times the next number
17.
then the question is
how much does Terry
how much is not the price there's no
price that you can give for Terry's time
but what is the value that has been
taken away from Terry what is the value
I mean they're lawyers and experts and
lots of people here that
are making you know low wages but a lot
of people are making four 300 400 500 an
hour
well I'm just suggesting a number and
you can put in whatever number you want
this is for the non-economic damages
Terry yogas every day
so
that's the next number
16 times 365 times 17.
I'm going to suggest a number you put in
the number you think is fair for Terry
the full value of the harms and losses
that he's dealing with every day
I'm going to say 33 dollars
33 dollars
and I've done the math because I told
you in the opening
you know except for the small change at
the end you know a couple hundred
dollars
this equation
is three million 276 thousand dollars
for the 17 years that Terry has to deal
with this permanent brain injury
yeah you could you could say well
you know it's Priceless but you know an
old shoe is that's priceless no this is
the most valuable time of his life
and it so that's the amount
that I suggest you consider
so what is this case not about
it's not about celebrity
it's not about that
yeah they're lots of indications of that
but this is about a man's life
what does the defense want to make this
case about they want to make it about
Terry's
multiple issues the 69 year old Terry
that was on that Hill oh yeah he had all
sorts of medical problems but the
defense wants to make it about that
but that didn't mean I mean he was
skiing on that hill at Deer Valley
I can't think of any place I'd rather be
skiing than Deer Valley uh maybe you
know Back Country powder where but
the point is he was healthy enough to
ski and now he doesn't ski
now I'm going to tell you a quick story
about The Legend of King Morgan
King Morgan was the real king
back in England about a thousand years
ago
back then the kings were the law
they someone had to dispute a farmer
knocked an eye out of his neighbor it
was eye for an eye Justice they'd take
the eye out of the guy who did it
and the Vic what did the victim get
nothing
well King Morgan one day said
you know what I'm going to invite 10 of
my or 12 of my
Nobles you know the guys that have the
littler castles and I'm going to have
them come in and I'm going to have him
listen to a case
and he heard their the Nobles heard the
case and then they
they made they said well we think this
should be decided this way and the King
said yeah you're right and that's good
so they did it a few more times and
finally the king said you guys decide
the cases I'm going to go off and do
what Kings do and hunt and fish and
fight battles
well that's the same system
that was adopted in the Magna Carta
almost a thousand years or 800 years ago
and it's the same system that was
brought over by the pilgrims
that we celebrate Thanksgiving for and
it's the same system in our country and
we're the only country that still has
the jury system where people like you
decide the cases
Winston Churchill
the Prime Minister of England during
World War II he said America is a great
country
and one of the reasons it's so great is
its jury system and it's no other
country has it
and if you want to
weaken America
take away its jury system
thank you
we'll take a short recess before we
continue
maybe about 15 minutes
producer
thank you are we ready for the jury
we are okay
we're ready for the jury
can we be clear on time I think they
took a full hour and do they all right
do you see it
all right thank you Mr Owens you ready
to proceed thank you yes just be clear
because James is going to share the time
with me sure and that is the plan of
preserve any time for rebuttal they
Reserve 10 minutes which I granted them
and so do they have an hour and 10
minutes and do we have an hour and 10
minutes they reserved they reserved 10
minutes so you you can proceed so we
have one hour you can take one hour and
if it happens to go over because you're
finishing a topic or something that's
fine thank you so much
well folks we didn't even know each
other two weeks ago and here we are
thank you
uh it's a beautiful thing I think that
we resolve disputes in our country in
this way just like Lawrence mentioned
you're plucked and really against your
will even if you had to fight it in
theory one of these bailiffs could go
arrest you and come and make you come
here
so we don't do that with anything else
but why do we do it
because it's such an important thing to
resolve disputes in our country in a
peaceful manner
so thank you
I miss Paul throws and I'm going to just
call her Gwyneth I missed I'm gwyneth's
lawyer I'm her spokesman this week
so she sat there for two weeks and been
a punching bag
we've blown through a lot of
these cute little uh
Post-it notes where she's sending me
stuff
but I take it very seriously because
she's comfortable in a lot of Worlds I'm
not comfortable in but she is not
comfortable in this world
it is not a nice thing for someone to
throw a press conference and say like
King Kong you knocked her knocked him
out and walked away
skied away
that is not what happened
and the court is actually dismissed
the the idea and that's one of your
endurance instructions that this was a
hit and run
that took no small amount of work by the
way
but that is what she was faced with
it takes a lot of Courage does it not
for her to sit there for two weeks and
be pounded like a punching bag
what did she lose
she lose all that's too bad you had to
come in early and have a massage no
this is what she lost
she was in love with Brad falchuk
dated for two years
they both had very interesting I think
nine-year-old sons and 11 year old
daughters it's kind of cool
and they said how are we gonna
get these guys together in a loving fun
time they're very busy
where we can kind of all be together for
a couple days and see if this will work
if we can blend our families together
we're going to be make it relaxed we're
going to put a lot of planning so put a
lot of planning into that trip
and so here they are it's a little
delicate because our anyone who's been
through like trying to blend families
it's a delicate thing
so what happened
they got there they're organized first
day of skiing they have ski instructors
by the way I thought it was cool I don't
know if you did her dad taught her to
ski at Alta
and she has tender feelings about that
she's been fearful with me in describing
those ski trips with her dad because her
dad died in his 50s in fact it was so
painful she didn't ski for a long time
after that because she would miss her
dad
but when her kids were of this age
and were talking with Brad Brad was a
big skier we didn't get to hear from him
unfortunately lack of time
but they were going to come okay let's
get our kids together
so what did they lose
they lost a half day of bonding and even
more because now everyone's stressed
that was the day when you Bond up going
up the ski lift they bond having hot
chocolate
mid-afternoon they bond relaxed laughing
around the fire
at night
they lost that because he hit her
he hit her
he hurt her
and then he asked her for three million
dollars for the pleasure
that is not fair
and I'm grateful that we have a court
system that permits anyone to sue anyone
for about a 250 dollar fee
and that they can
have their day in court and I think Mr
Sanderson by all accounts will have some
peace after this trial regardless but
it's come at a
steep cost
a deep cost to my client
I told you when we first met
I wanted to concentrate on a couple
things about Lady Justice here by the
way if I didn't make it clear you are
Lady Justice
all right
blindfold eyes because she's blind no
she's smart
but she's not going to be distracted by
a chaos around her
chaos like media
chaos like
sympathy oh I don't we all feel bad for
him
I would have liked by the way at least a
discount on the camel ride on on your
request for damages but that's another
issue the idea is okay
we're going to focus we're going to
focus and we've tried and the judge has
given you all these warnings don't be
talking to people don't even talk to
yourselves yet because we want you
focused and that's that's Lady Justice
now I talked to you earlier about the
scales of Justice
this is a civil claim meaning the
preponderance of the evidence
the plaintiffs brought the lawsuit
that's why we're all here his daughters
say isn't it terrible these two
daughters that he's brought here his
life is laid open it's because of him
he hit her he hurt her and he wants
three million dollars for it
that's not fair the easy thing for my
client would have been to write a check
and be done with it but what does that
tell her kids
it
you just well it's cost of business no
it's wrong it's actually wrong
that he hurt her and he wants money from
her and that's why we're here
all right so the back to the scales here
on Lady Justice
he has the burden to tilt
okay Tai goes to her
now she has a one dollar counter claim
my wife said don't wave the dollar and
I'm not waving the dollar
but a dead even tie
means neither get anything and I'll walk
you through that in just a minute but
let me suggest it's not even close let
me suggest it's like this the evidence
here versus here and let me talk to you
about that let me mention a couple other
jury instructions so I talked to you
about no sympathy passion or Prejudice
we don't want you making decisions on
that basis I talked to you about the
burden of proof
that is theirs and then from today let
me talk to you about a few things
by the way the burden of proof was
evident because they get the last word
because they have to tilt the things you
may have noticed this morning they could
call a witness and after I'm done they
can speak for a few more minutes and
that's that's what we do to the people
who have a burden of proof instruction
30 that you were read today
Gwyneth Paltrow did not leave the scene
of the accident
without giving her contact information
press conference four years ago
King Kong came out of the jungle
left me unconscious and and and brushed
off and went away
utterly BS and it's been discounted it's
not even before you
the judge took that away from you
because it was so obviously false
31 deals with spoilation that's the
GoPro issue spoilingation's probably a
word you never heard before it's a legal
term but the idea is if they destroy
evidence you can assume that it was bad
for them
all right so Terry in fact I should say
Mr Sanderson in fact owned a GoPro
all right
he talked to his daughter that night
6 p.m so about six hours after the
Collision
she got off the phone with the
understanding that he had a GoPro video
of the incident
and type to him I am so glad that
there's a GoPro
and that you're okay
all right no one has the GoPro
but I'm telling you this if you find
that there was a GoPro
and that he said hmm
that will not help my case
delete
if that happened you can conclude
that it was a uh against him that it
helped us and wouldn't have been nice if
it had been around
do you remember when we talked eight
nine days ago I said you're going to
hear so much stuff about damages
so much stuff
but if you find that he hit her
you can ignore it
so we heard like a week of testimony
about Mr sanderson's brain and how he
thinks
he does like to be the center of
attention he likes to be in the
spotlight his own daughter said he would
be dishonest for money or notoriety
does that make you like uncomfortable it
makes me really uncomfortable
when Dr Gibby was up there he said oh he
has a great relationship with his
daughters it's like
who he says two two daughters there are
three daughters you can't just pretend
this stuff away three daughters it's
pretty important isn't it for a witness
to know that he's he's not
in the least good relationship and why
because she said he was he was abusive
um and a lot of other uh adjectives that
I'm not actually actually will defer to
you to remember
so miss Paltrow is asking for her dollar
daughter dollar but it's not about the
dollar it's not about
uh I mean think of what her time is
worth sitting here for two weeks
it's not about the money
it's about kind of ruining a very
delicate time in a relationship where
they're trying to get their kids
together that's what Terry Sanderson
caused her
pre-existing conditions oh my gosh
how do we not talk about
what was going on right before and what
versus what's happened after
he's 76 I mean my parents I hate I'm not
being flippant they were dead
by then you certainly weren't taking 10
trips around the world
so we have to look at that
those are the
those are the jury instructions I do
want to tell you the special verdict
form that was appropriate can you bring
that up
Lawrence walked you through it and I
don't think there's any harm in me
telling you what I want is there
I'm going to ask you to to fill this out
this is what you go to the
delivery when you deliberate these three
pages the last page really is nothing
so it's essentially nine questions
and
I want I want to show you how I want you
to fill it out I'm not trying to be
subtle
all right so was Gwyneth Paltrow at
fault
no
if you answer no go to question three so
next page
then you have to that that means Terry
sanderson's not going to take any money
away from today if you write no so no on
one you are done kind of in terms of his
claim then you go to paragraph three
which is our claim
was Terry Sanderson at fault yes we want
you to say yes was this fault a cause of
her harm again we're asserting one
dollar but it was so much more
it made everyone nervous all afternoon
was Terry sanderson's fault a cause yes
and then James if you answer
regardless of your answer go to Five if
your answers to Quest so this is like a
tax form where you have to like read it
four times sorry if your answers to
questions one and three are both no
one was Gwyneth at fault you should not
proceed any further and you go to the
end and sign it and this is because
you're feel you're trying to figure out
uh was she at fault yes or no was he at
fault yes or no did it cause any damage
you can actually find today
that neither were at fault
skiing is an interesting thing
we strap sticks on our legs at the top
of a very high heel
and go down for fun
it's breathtaking I've done it I love it
but it has inherent wrists so the back
of every ski pass you've ever seen judge
objection you've excluded this and here
in the risk of scheme we reference this
your honor you said it applies to
Resorts not to people no no the argument
is a proper so overruled so inherent
risk you've seen it on the back of every
ski pass and even your own common sense
says hey if I don't go down this hill
right I could actually kill myself
so
skiing is different it's even different
than driving
I mean we don't drive cars downhills
right down the icy hills but we do ski
down the icy hills
the Deer Valley guy would say where
never I see at Deer Valley
but nevertheless it's kind of a
dangerous thing and uh so you can
actually say no don't get me wrong I
want Gwyneth paid for the for this
the hardship Mr Sanderson caused her
he hit her he hurt her and he's not
entitled to sue her
I'm sorry he's entitled to be here today
but he's not entitled to be rewarded for
hurting her that's not how this country
works
all right James let's see
then if we go other
if your answers to one and three are
both no you should not proceed further
so if you found not at fault not at
fault you're done you go to the end and
you're four person signs it but if you
keep going otherwise continue to six
James
what I would I couldn't do this without
James if you can't tell what percent of
the fault to you assigned to have Paul
throw
so then you have to figure out a
percentage
it's possible that both people are at
fault
and how this works is you take a hundred
percent pi and you find out okay
one is ten percent at fault Terry's
ninety percent at fault so you a lot of
things aren't just so obvious like gray
and white black and white
we would obviously if you get this far
we'd want you to put zero apportionment
to her
Terry a hundred percent
I guess you could find that Gwen is
entitled to 75 cents and not one dollar
believe it or not
okay then we keep going
James whatever you can find here
what amount compensates Terry Sanders
and we just want you to go to nine and
give us our dollar there was a little
issue raised about whether her
attorney's fees could be added to that
the judges said I'm going to deal with
that that's not in front of you
all right so you're in your your topic
is this dollar
believability of witnesses this was one
of your earlier instructions how do I
figure out who's telling the truth here
and I'm going to put Craig Ramon
first of all Terry doesn't know doesn't
remember much there was one just blatant
misstatement in their closing which was
Terry could talk to a wall for two hours
and have a pretty good conversation that
was before the incident
so that was misrepresented as being
after the incident every time that issue
came up I said before
yes before
all right
uh let's go to
talking about evaluating Witnesses
I'm telling you if we were in law school
and we had a class about eyewitness how
an eye claimed eyewitness
is actually sees what he thinks he sees
Craig Ramon would be the definition of a
bad witness and I'm going to give you
some objective statements about that
he's at the end of the Court
he says I'm skiing
and there at the end
I'm colorblind
I have imperfect vision
I don't know what they're wearing
I'm looking at other things I'm not
focused on them he said he hears and
turns well guess what Eric Christensen
the ski instructor who they accuse of a
cover-up which was dismissed
heard and turned
he he's he they're the same they heard
and turned
Craig describes himself as an eyewitness
Eric said I didn't see the Collision I
just heard and turned they saw the same
things
interestingly Eric came right over and
now's appropriate time to watch our
little fun video
I don't know if you like these
animations but we kind of put them
together so that you guys can kind of
Envision all this information coming at
you
so doc Eric Sanderson or excuse me Eric
Christensen did you like the guy
the the guy is like oh my gosh I love
this guy he's been doing it for 40 years
he teaches art on the side he's been a
lifelong resident he's married to
someone whose whole life is skiing and
he is not a liar he is not someone who
covers up he is not someone who
falsifies reports all of those
allegations were thrown out so we're not
dealing with Deer Valley
interestingly it's not just Ramon versus
Christensen because all the Deer Valley
people did you do you remember the cool
Whitney who took the toboggan woman I
mean she's an amazing witness she's up
there oh I'm assessing things all left
and right you know nothing nothing
nothing but that's a little different so
we're gonna play this and I think Moses
is an orange
and there's Terry so Eric Christensen
says he sees Terry out of the corner of
his eye well he looks and sees because
he's trying to he's in charge of sort of
protecting these kids so he says he's
always looking up the mountain
and then uh he hears and turns and then
the next view the next one
by the way no one has no one but Craig
has the guy the the guy spread out
spread eagle with his head down the hill
there's no facial damage to his face
his skis stayed on you've heard from
these structural
bioengineering people if he came and got
hit like Craig described
his skis would have popped right off
you don't you don't keep your skis when
you get blown Sanderson says he was
Airborne that he was flying
first of all I'm not going to get into
the weight have him sit on scales
but miss twice by the way not once twice
Sanderson Mr Sanderson said I'm I'm this
I'm three inches shorter in 2015 pounds
lighter we're not talking about today
we're talking about then then he was
three inches I don't know if he shrunk
three inches since then but he's called
described himself as pudgy
he's coming downhill at a faster pace
I mean uh
anyway the structural engineering people
which is kind of interesting not
structural biomedical engineering people
I don't know if you got bored in that
part or was interested but I'm telling
you the science does not work for for
Craig's Theory okay
so we're going to play this Mr
Christensen am I in your way judge no
there's Moses Terry Oaks Apple it's a
little hard to absorb but here's Gwyneth
and there's Sanderson
now let me tell you what Sanderson said
and he said it just at the end of the
day yesterday I said tell me what's
going on right before the incident
he said there was a lady on his left
that was kind of tentative
so I deliberately I think I said passing
on your on the right pretty sure I did
so there's the woman he describes in
green
and he's trying to sort of he's watching
her he is blind in his right eye he said
I use that term loosely he's an
optometrist for heaven's sakes he's
blind in that eye from a stroke
he is caught helped him contribute to
his retirement okay so he's watching and
imagine imagine this I'm blind in my
right eye and I'm really mindful of not
hitting this woman to the left of me and
then he said
nobody could have passed on my left
except the gal I just passed so that gal
I was real conscious of because I still
worried about her and so as I went past
her I went inches inches per second past
her I just remember it took forever for
me to get past her and there were skis
and then that's when the Collision
happened all right so maybe run it one
last time James
so he's looking to his left with a blind
dry eye to make sure he doesn't hit the
woman
he's looking to his left and what
happens Gwyneth described in
praise to the judge for not letting this
be reenacted with Gwyneth and being
assaulted in front of us all
she is skiing and two skis come in
between her
and she's they this is not a big hill by
the way I mean this is these are kind of
photographs this isn't just claymation
here and it comes in and she's like what
is happening
they're not going that fast but Terry's
going faster because he's
his skis are coming in between her it's
because he's looking with his one by the
way he has like half an eye because he
has a cataract in the left eye
hearing shot
and he says I I'm getting too old uh I
can't do everything I can well I mean I
stopped playing Church basketball after
my knee injury I'm like I love it but
I'm I I can't do it anymore okay so
sometimes we have to give things up
especially when we're 76 years old I'm
sorry I mean that's life but she comes
in between he comes in between her legs
she's going what is going on here
it's not like a ski Collision hit you're
out
and uh he's grunting his bodies against
her
she's thinking am I being assaulted like
because this isn't really a ski
Collision
and then they go for a little while she
said spooning
and then and whatever the next Imaging
next animation would be James and then
they go to their Le to their right
now I don't know you've heard the ribs
issue by the way if you're 76 with
osteoporosis you can hit you can break
your ribs
you may see in this records in your
documents these weren't dramatic breaks
I mean two weren't were not even
distended dislocated
what's the right word
this
placed thank you two were not displaced
and two were just very minor displaced
did they hurt I'm sure they heard them
I'm sure they did
all right so
she is on Top Eric Christensen said she
was on top
and uh their skis are intertwined
and what is he doing she's like what's
okay I see I see what's I'm not being
assaulted
and he may well have hit his head he
does have a helmet on so does she by the
way Craig Ramon's like no no helmet he
tried to change his testimony on the
sand but I'd question him like five
years earlier no he's she didn't have I
was really surprised she no helmet no
mask give me a break for anonymity
purposes as well as safety uh this is a
person skiing with her kids
she's pretty focused on safety let me
just tell you that all right so she
what's the first thing does Eric
Christensen is this the last one
is this the last of the animations
only three were admitted I think there
were five three full ones three whatever
you can take us to next well but you've
already shown three there were there
were three videos that were Eric that
were entered in their total and then
there were two only partial oops is that
right correct okay so whatever you can
get two partials that didn't show the
actual impact
only Craig has their heads downhill
Moses
Who You'd love him if he's these cute
little 16 year old now uh he's but we
didn't get it we only got to hear him
he skis over because he doesn't hear
anything but his his instructor comes
over he comes over and he sees his mom
on the ground
now downhill because she's gotten away
from this guy okay I'm I'm I'm safe
the idea of an assault just entered her
mind she said for a short couple seconds
because she's going what's going on
this is the overhead view and run it as
you can here's Miss Paltrow
pal throw
Apple Moses
here's Miss pal throw
here's the beginning skier woman
here's Sanderson and he's gonna she's
making these small turns on the right
he's making big turns
he's a lot faster
he's a lot more advanced skier I should
say
all right
here's Christensen you remember we
placed him
Carrie Oaks went on ahead with Apple
Apple told me she heard a commotion but
she was hangry for french fries and she
just wanted to get down the hill
uh Moses is here and so uh uh there we
go
okay any other animations
looking up hill
I'll throw in Black
Sanderson
beginning skier in green
woman
watch Sanderson
and then we're done so it's probably
that third one that two back that's
probably the most powerful of them in
terms of showing you
the layout
all right how many how am I doing on
time folks I want to leave James 10 or
15 minutes
30 minutes so far thanks so I'm gonna
ten after thanks judge
after they've separated Brad falter uh
comes up she skis down but there's then
this period of time so here's Eric
Christensen
Eric Christensen said I came over to
find out
what had happened
they say he came over to bully him
Deer Valley employees who bully their
guests get fired he's been there 40
years you could see if his grandfather
lead demeanor
makes sense under Craig Ramon's story it
doesn't it doesn't Eric comes over and
he says the first thing I'm doing I'm
taking off skis remember under all
stories no skis came off that tells you
something about the the the manner of
the Collision doesn't it it wasn't a
like Ramon describes flat out straight
by the way Ramon oh my gosh he says he's
out cold for two or more minutes
do you know what what and what did you
do about it nothing
nothing
could you imagine looking at an
unconscious person
splayed out head down
skis on
for over two minutes could you imagine
I'm like did you call 9-1-1 did you
check for breathing no
no none of that
I mean good grief give me a break
all right
Eric Christensen comes over and says
okay let's take skis off
remember he had some personal knowledge
because he had he knew kind of wrote
where Gwyneth was and he kind of knew
where Eric Christensen was
he knew where they were downhill versus
uphill and he knew their skill level he
could tell he said he could tell because
uh that um
Mr Sanderson was an advanced skier
because he didn't slide I I didn't
really know this but
if you do kind of use skiers will maybe
know if you can work your edges and you
don't slide apparently that means you're
a more advanced skier
okay so he comes over he's trying to
figure out what's going on
but he actually knows some things
Gwyneth is pissed off
if you hit someone do you yell at the
person you just hit
no
the hitty and I've been hit skiing
is is usually the unhappy one
but she recognizes these things happen
until he says did you hit me
and she's now she's mad because not only
is he hurt her and hit her but now he's
saying
no I I don't think I think you caused
this and then she's like are you kidding
me you just ran in my effing back and
Moses heard it
all right
so then Christensen who I think is just
a fabulous witness I think everything he
said is just utterly true it it's
consistent with everything he took off
skis
I said was San it was Sanderson ever out
cold no
if he was it was like it would have been
like like that
Gwyneth how was he out cold for two
minutes
no he wasn't out cold at all
don't you think people would be going
like crazy if there was a man splayed
out on Deer Valley
head down out cold for minutes
that's not a believable story Eric
Christensen now is engaging people
when it's mad but she's okay in the
sense that she doesn't need help she can
still ski but she said her her knee
which she'd already had surgery on hurt
and she has sustained a blow I mean
I don't know if you've ever been hit
even if you're in a football game and
you're all padded up
he he
she had sustained a blow she was upset
and then this idea of
him not sort of she she says you know
you just did this and then what did he
say
sorry
does the person who got hit say they're
sorry no the hit or says I'm sorry and
he said it I'm sorry I'm sorry okay now
she's okay okay he's not gonna he's not
denying
the stupid thing he just did but okay
now we got to sit around and kind of
sort things out then air christensen's
goes to Sanderson
uh
tell me what you want to say and he said
she appeared right in front of me that's
what he said in his report
she appeared right in front of me
that's consistent with gweneth being mad
and saying you just skied into my effing
back
and it's consistent with Chris with
Christensen seeing
kind of what was going on he was the
uphill skier he he knew that
and there you go that's uh if
everything's consistent
now if he'd said I didn't do it
she hit me
okay whoa whoa now we got to investigate
and then you recall so
so okay it's clear who did who did what
Christensen says to Ramon
your buddy just took out Gwyneth Paltrow
I think this was just after she skied
away
and what did Ramon say did you correct
him
no
that's the time to say no I saw it and
she hit him
that was the time Ramon didn't say a
word he just sat there
he's not helping his unconscious friend
and he's not denying under his story
what the ski uh Deer Valley
representative has just determined your
buddy took out her
all right so that's the time to do it
not later do you remember one of the
things I said in opening is rely on
the evidence before there's thoughts of
lawsuits because then you can kind of
rely people aren't thinking okay 10
minutes later oh my gosh Gwyneth Paltrow
wow that's something else we were just
in a collision with Gwyneth Paltrow
now people are thinking okay
wow
famous
they're not thinking that yet in real
time he's saying I'm sorry
and then are you okay
everyone always asks this question are
you okay
and he said I'm okay now he tried to
change it a little bit and we had to go
to his transcript but he agreed he said
I'm okay
and then
ski patrollers come by so I mean
there it would have to be a pretty vast
conspiracy against Deer Valley for this
to be a cover-up and remember they were
already dismissed
ski patrollers come by they see some
stuff going on
everyone all right over there
Eric Christensen did not answer that
question
because this is a contact now between
injured skier and ski patrol Eric says
ski instructor
and so what how what what happened Eric
he said they talked
so this isn't
we're not in there like trying to
bully someone
Craig spoke to Terry privately he said
Eric said I can I couldn't hear it
and then
which obviously Terry at some point said
he remembers Terry saying are you okay
are you okay
so there's there's a connection and then
what did they say
we're okay and the ski patrollers left
all right so that's what's happening in
real time now we go to the paperwork
why don't we why don't we fill out a big
deal get everyone's statements and
everything because if this happens all
the time on ski resorts if everyone's
okay
okay I mean we we don't we don't have a
scene about it
but they go down a little longer they
know and now know that that Miss Paltrow
was part of the Collision
and then Terry and you can believe him
you can believe them
but they now know
I'm not skinned too well I don't feel
that well
all right
fair enough
it did come 10 minutes after they found
out who they had been involved with all
right bring in Whitney Whitney's an
awesome geez I thought she was a
fabulous witness she pulls up and hurt
she's all business like uh okay I'm
gonna assess for unconsciousness no what
happened she says what happened to Terry
he didn't say I got hit he says I don't
remember I don't know
did Craig
immediately
go in on that
we'll have to defer to her a report that
was a legitimate question of mine I'm
trying to remember
James when are you up
are you up in five
I can do that
that gives you five or ten
excuse me fifteen
thanks I'm gonna be I'm going to be done
in five minutes folks
okay
so
Whitney's delightful
loads them up takes them down says hey
before I want you to remember five
things and this isn't like man woman dog
this is like
I got my degree in Michigan I was Deer
Valley grand slam person whatever all
these really details I like horses my
horse's name all this stuff remember it
Terry says I remember I knew I was now
having a cognition
memory test performed upon me he goes
down and she then says do you remember
and oh my gosh he remembered in fact he
remembered so well he decided this is a
good opportunity for me to text and post
a picture of Whitney smiling and just
talk about how wonderful she is
Whitney meanwhile is sitting there
trying to figure out okay are any
problems here are you seeing any signs
of concussion no
I'm not
uh do you remember Dr Edgley I don't
know if you thought that was cool that a
guy
who heads up the used acquired Brain
Injury Clinic
has had an acquired brain injury
I thought it was kind of cool anyway he
goes what do you look at you look at a
period of unconsciousness we have Craig
versus all these people saying he's not
and he wasn't unconscious
they even imply like Christensen would
didn't even care about us he's yelling
at us he's bullying us and then he's
abandoning us on the conscious drooling
onto the mountain give me a break is
that what you don't know dear Valley to
be
so so then okay he checks out at the at
the main Clinic then he's down to the
InstaCare what is that InstaCare uh PA
looking he's looking for no
I don't see any sign signs of symptoms
of unconsciousness or concussion
because they're looking at memories
they're looking at periods of
unconsciousness and they're looking at
uh this is the third do you recall
memory
attached to you
that's that means inability to speech I
don't think that is what they were
looking for
in any case they're looking for any
signs and the symptoms of uh
concussion no now that doesn't mean he
didn't have a concussion
but it does mean this is not this isn't
anything severe at all I mean okay next
day goes to the VA these are the people
he knows
CT guess what they're like they're like
all the same abnormalities as you had in
your brain before
the problem is
and by the way he then goes for three
neural assessments and they all say
normal normal to above normal in some
ways really above normal
so neural no assessments those are
always treating providers why would we
have our experts go do neural
assessments when three separate treating
providers that he knows and trusts and
that no one's paying say above normal
why would we do that
but the problem is he then goes to Gibby
and Fong
and he just self-reports everything was
normal beforehand
wrong
and now everything's terrible
he doesn't tell him he's good flying all
over the world that he's biking that
he's the poster boy for a fitness at age
75 he's posting every darn thing I mean
this isn't like me sending out a private
investigator and trying to find pictures
all I have to do is put Terry Sanderson
oh my gosh the guys missed her activity
Heaven Help me if I can be as active as
he is at 75.
all right I have one more minute
I'm going to go back to lay beat Lady
Liberty so we talked about the blindfold
Lady Justice excuse me we talked about
the blindfold and we talked about uh the
scale
the sword
we want you to use the sword this sounds
harsh because we're not beheading anyone
the sword is to defend a meritless claim
this is a meritless claim
you don't throw a three million dollar
bombshell in the courtroom caller King
Kong and walk away
you shouldn't reward that
and Gwyneth who could have just paid it
out
paid the ransom
no
I'm not doing that I'm not going to have
someone hurt me
and then
put me ask me for a lot of money
I'm not going to do it I'm going to sit
here I said you're going to have to sit
here for two weeks in Park City and you
can't even look at your phone
and she said I'm going to do it
I'm not paying that
we ask you for the dollar
not because she had to go in and get an
early massage but it screwed up a very
carefully planned important part time in
her life
I think Heaven's the family melded well
together
but we want our dollar
thank you for your time
judge we approached briefly sure
Mr Egan you may proceed all right thank
you your honor
are you guys hearing this okay
Okay so
it's my job uh to talk about Mr
sanderson's claim that he's not living
the life that he used to live and it's
Miss Paltrow's fault I hope I can be
helpful to you as we walk through some
of this I wanted to start by just
pointing to this document this you
remember Whitney Smith was the the ski
patrol that arrived and wrote this
report that day a little bit later
uh Mr Owens could not uh recall an
important fact this is the witness
section at the bottom is not filled out
Mr Ramon did not come forward and say
this is what happened let me tell you
about it
Whitney Smith would have written that in
there if he did
she uh also
pointed to we also pointed to the fact
that she did not write an ex at that
concussion
and head boxes where she could have
noted possible injury she's to use one
of Mr Sykes phrases she has no dog in
this fight she would have put X's there
if she was concerned about that she
didn't
you also heard her talk about
um
mild disorientation in her
uh report
and that shows up here
and I think you've seen that the
um
I'm sorry
I'm sorry this thing can be finicky
you've seen it I'll just move forward
for the sake of time there's those mild
disorientation notes right and she
explained that she didn't see that as an
indication of concussion she just saw it
as being kind of rattled from a ski
Collision
and that's relevant to damages because
Mr Sanderson is claiming that he had a
concussion and all the symptoms that
have come from the Collision relate back
to that concussion I think there's
there's a considerable doubt that he
even had one he may have and you could
certainly find that but you might find
that he he didn't have a concussion
um I think though that I want to I want
to kind of frame this in a with a
certain theme maybe you've seen a
pattern over the course of these last
couple weeks or the last two weeks
um
on the one hand you have real events and
then on the other hand you have
embellishments on the one hand you have
objective tests and on the other hand
you have subjective reports
on the one hand you have what happened
in the past and then on the other hand
you have perception of what happened in
the past
the realities of life sometimes
difficult realities
and on the other hand you have anxious
exaggerations
I think Mr Ramon took the reality of the
collision and spun it into an
attention-grabbing story for friends
about dramatic injuries and celebrity he
was talking a lot about that uh Miss
Smith overheard it as she was caring for
Mr Sanderson and then there were those
comments that we found in the middle of
trial where he kind of he talked about
it and you heard him explain that he'd
been talking about it with French he
knew a lot about Miss Paltrow he's very
interested in this I think he took that
reality of the collision and embellished
that what happened what he saw and Mr
sanderson's taken the reality of his
aging body and he's turned it into a
profound Injustice perpetrated by Miss
Paltrow it isn't that
the fact show that his health challenges
started long before the Collision
and they've progressed in a predictable
way
I think you heard Dr Hesh yesterday say
if you look at his medical records you
look through the history you take the
the the Collision out of that timeline
it reads coherently the prior stuff
would predict the next stuff you don't
need the Collision to explain what
happens afterwards
it's not to say that he didn't have
injuries in the Collision nobody
disputes the broken ribs
um and those were certainly painful they
did heal
um and then the concussion if he had one
was very brief as you heard multiple
experts say yesterday and had very mild
symptoms that may have even resolved
within that day so even if you find that
Miss Paltrow caused the accident I think
you only have sufficient evidence to
find damages that that relate to those
broken ribs and the the concussion that
resolved very quickly
um
this the slow degeneration of uh bodies
is hard to accept and mental health
challenges are hard to face that's it's
obviously human to want a concrete
explanation for these difficulties
but as the court has instructed you Mr
Sanderson should not receive the money
he asked for if you find that his
perceptions do not match reality the law
requires that he convince you that more
likely than not he has suffered real
harm that Miss Paltrow is the and that
Miss Paltrow is the cause of that harm
and he has not done that
through the course of the trial you've
seen that Mr Sanderson does have genuine
problems and I don't want to minimize
that uh experts from both sides have
talked about his anxiety and depression
and the trouble he's had with family and
relationships before and after the
accident uh you know we've seen brain
scans Dr Black came in here and he was
the only expert I believe that took you
through all of them and explained how
they you know were back in 2009 look
very similar to what you've seen going
forward they're connected to
abnormalities related to to aging and
other conditions that might explain his
his problems
um
but he's Mr sanderson's argued that you
should believe his experts because they
evaluated him personally
the problem I think with that argument
is that as you've learned these past two
weeks these experts didn't carefully
review his medical history and they
relied heavily on his unreliable reports
about it
they also want you to believe what
they've been calling the before and
after Witnesses those the family and the
daughters uh the sorry the daughters the
the friend and then the girlfriend
and I I think that you've learned these
past two weeks that they didn't know Mr
sanderson's Health as well as they
thought they did
and he was actually they had I think
acknowledged that he's good at hiding
some of those issues maybe totally
understandably and reluctant to share
his troubles
so you have objective facts and then
subjective reports and the law requires
you to find evidence reality not just
the perception of problems
um from our experts you've heard a
consistent compelling account
that Mr Sanderson uh
had these problems before that the
concussion occurred potentially again
very briefly if at all and that those
conditions that he's experienced
afterward that he attributes to miss
Paltrow are the predictable consequence
of that prior history they were you
heard them all yesterday I guess you had
Dr Edgley the night before but you heard
them all and it's a coherent consistent
story I think you've got a sense that
they've read the records carefully the
objective records of treaters who
haven't again no dog in this fight just
reporting what is going on for many uh
many many years before and after the
Collision
your honor I have till 25 yes okay five
more minutes I got a lot I'm not going
to get it to all again I'll try to get
to The Helpful stuff
um
Mr Owens went through the the various
evidence about loss of consciousness
um and the different witnesses that have
um I hope persuaded you that Mr
Sanderson did not get knocked out for
multiple minutes
but Dr eastvolt gave you some
interesting testimony yesterday she said
that the medical records after the
accident are actually inconsistent with
serious concussion injury there was the
cognitive assessments he pointed to that
were normal there was the balance
assessment that was normal you wouldn't
expect it to be normal and then there
was the alcohol intake that actually
increased even though a concussion would
reduce intolerance for alcohol again
careful looking at the events in
question which I don't think you heard
plaintiff's experts do
Mr sanderson's perception is different
obviously he not only thinks he was
knocked out for minutes but he he said
he had a profound cognitive trouble
during this time with Miss Smith who
said he was cognitively intact could
speak to him he was writing particular
posts about her could carry on
conversation for hours
so you've got careful evaluation on the
one hand and then you have extreme
exaggeration on the other
and the law requires you to be careful
in your evaluation
um
Mr Sanderson sees the time immediately
following the Collision as a grim period
that began a spiral uh again spiraling
his life out of control I think he
described the bright side before and
then the dark side afterwards and I
think it's important to recognize that
as as we've probably told you too many
times a few weeks just prior to this
Collision he was reporting some of the
symptoms and the concerns he's he's
saying connect to the Collision right
he's said he was getting old all of a
sudden he couldn't do things that he
used to do to get preoccupied with
paperwork and other little things and
that's difficult and I don't mean to
make light of that kind of reality that
aging brings upon all of us but it's
important that at that time there was no
litigation he's just reporting and you
heard from experts that point to that as
a Telltale sign of the kinds of things
you would expect after the Collision
um that he's he's attributing to miss
Paltrow yeah
Mr sanderson's told you that the
Collision forced him to be a recluse and
if we had time I would pull up those
pictures we went through a lot of them
and I hope that wasn't overboard there's
you got a sense of just how much he has
done since the Collision traveled more
than some people have traveled in their
whole lives
and I I think it's it's that this three
million dollar I don't know where the
board is three million dollar claim I
think doesn't acknowledge that reality
Mr Sanderson is better than he realizes
that he is
and it's not that he doesn't have
problems it's just that he is better
than he realizes he is and it's it's
hard for him to accept some of the the
decline that he's experienced
um and he's again
uh grabbed onto this Collision as as an
uh an explanation for it
um
you've heard from Dr Hesh and Dr Edgley
about how litigation contributes to
problems like he's had and you heard
even from his own expert Dr Goldstein
that he's obsessed with this this case
and it's not good for him that that
moving on would be
um helpful for him
and uh
and I think that it we we all want
resolution to this case Mr sanderson's
asking to be compensated for a ski
injury that the evidence shows that he
himself caused
and the evidence also shows that his
life is not the mess he perceives it to
be
Miss Paltrow wants him off the mountain
too
but she should not be responsible for
the cost of that and so we leave you
with that argument hope that you can of
course hope you persuaded and thank you
for listening
thank you Mr Egan Mr Sorensen
thank you thank you for being here
we appreciate the time and attention
that you've spent with us the last
couple weeks going on kind of this
journey
there's been a lot of fanfare a lot of
hubbub about this you've seen a lot of
Technology some has failed as we've seen
today but some has worked
and through all of that I want to remind
you of jury instruction number 24. okay
and it says
when the lawyers are giving their
closing arguments keep in mind that
they're advocating their views of the
case
what they say during closing arguments
is not evidence
if the lawyers say anything about the
evidence that conflicts with what you
remember you are to rely on your memory
of the evidence
if they say anything about the law that
conflicts with your with these
instructions you are to rely on these
instructions
now you've heard some pretty amazing
narratives a spin on the facts from and
you could probably say it cuts both ways
both sides but I want you to remember
about this case that there are two
stories here
one is Gwyneth Paltrow and you've heard
her heard defense attorneys lay out her
case
you've heard her side of the story
but there's also another side and that
is Terry Sanderson
they've done a really good job of
telling you about what Craig Ramon says
about how he describes this whole thing
happening
and what Gwyneth Paltrow says or what
Eric Christensen says
but the two stories that are important
to remember
are Terry sanderson's and Gwyneth
paltrows
Terry remembers
skiing down the mountain
hearing a scream directly behind him and
then bam as he put it lights out
okay
he's knocked unconscious
he's left on the mountain figuratively
as we've talked about
trying to figure out what's going on
when he comes to two it's it's chaos he
doesn't really understand what's going
on
the other hand we have
Gwyneth Paltrow
who says that she's skiing along and and
all of a sudden she gets hit from behind
it's up to you now to weigh that
evidence
to see what you remember what you recall
not the way that the attorneys
characterize the evidence but what you
see in the record
and I will tell you that what you see in
the record
corroborates the story of Terry
Sanderson
Terry Sanderson I just walked you
through his tale of what happened okay
his versions of facts that happened
when he's hit from behind he has to rely
on the one person remember that the one
person that says that they saw the
actual Collision
and saw what happened
has to rely on that
but it doesn't mean that it's not part
of his story
it means that he's relying on an
eyewitness that corroborates what he
said
also we have the block the Meetup Group
post that's been talked a lot about and
the comments to that post
that's contemporaneous evidence the day
of
that corroborates the story that these
two have shared with you
it says
and Craig Ramon's own words says it
scared the hell out of me
it scared him scared what he's he was
scared
so
that might be an account that you weigh
as to why he didn't step in to try to
give life-saving or or life supporting
measures to his friend
he's scared he doesn't know what's
happening and the person that he's
relying on to take charge of the
situation comes over and starts
screaming at him
it's also important to remember
that Brad falczek who we didn't get a
chance to hear from
and Carrie Oaks both contradict in major
ways
he admitted your honor and that was just
a minute um
just yeah that's true that wasn't that
was a stipulated fact
stipulated facts so thank you
Brad felchuk did not see it
okay Eric Christensen in his own
reporting didn't see the Collision
but yet right afterwards he injects
himself into this chaotic event and
according to him takes control he has
enough time
think about this when you're weighing
believability of testimony okay
Eric Christensen has enough time
and is all aware about the students that
he's being paid to watch and to teach
how to ski that are beginner students
watch what someone's doing on the other
side of the run at the same time
with as reported in the facts show many
people skiing on this run it's a
converging run that goes down to the the
bottom of the run where people can go
and have lunch
he has the ability to pay attention to a
young child who he's teaching
someone across the way
someone skiing supposedly out of control
and keep track of all this
he hears his scream and looks over and
sees as the animations that you've seen
him laying on the ground or sees these
two people laying on the ground
he then has enough time to be the first
on the scene supposedly
after telling Carrie Oaks
take care of the kids watch them because
I got to go over and take care of this
and he does that all it just fractions
of a second
is that believable
I'll leave that to you to decide
I know the way I feel about it
so this Witness
who the defense has said
his grandfatherly who's this perfect
Witness
is not really that perfect
again I'll leave that for you to decide
now A lot's been made of
what Terry Sanderson was saying or doing
after the incident right we have we've
you've heard and I don't want your eyes
to glaze over that's why I'm not using
any of the props I'm just talking to you
but
you've heard a lot about this email
right
the email Terry Sanderson sent later
that night or first email and the
response back okay and I want you to
remember this
the GoPro incident or the GoPro video I
guess we'll talk about this GoPro email
is a response from his daughter
who sat here and testified
three weeks before she'd been in she'd
been in her own ski accident she was
laying there with her leg up
she was under as I think she said she
had pain pills at the time she was
aching in injury and there might have
been kids coming in and out of her room
she didn't remember exactly why she
wrote what she wrote now unless she
admits that she wrote it and she said
here in front of you
that it was clearly a misunderstanding
to something her dad might have said
when he was on the phone with her
that's the shred of evidence
that they want you to cling on to
to try to say that Terry Sanderson did
something like destroy a video of this
event that's our only piece of evidence
that they put on in front of you
to that fact
now again
there are many contradictions in this
tall tale and the cartoons you've been
forced to watch a few times
and I want you to remember okay
there was testimony that Brad faucik was
on the mountain but he's not in their
videos he's not in their animations
okay you didn't see it
but there's testimony that he was right
up there close
they left him out
they left out Carrie Oaks and her
testimony we had to read it in
because she also contradicts the
positions of the bodies after the
incident
so they've done a really good job of
trying to Razzle Dazzle and trying to
get you to look at a lot of other things
that are not important because we told
you in the very beginning when Lawrence
Buehler stood up here
you'd hear a lot of so what
that's what they're saying about Terry
sanderson's injuries so what
he was injured before his injuries
carried through so what so sorry he's
left on the mountain we'd like him off
so what
that's what you're hearing
now
we have shown facts that are
corroborated
by his medical records that show that
from the day after this incident
happened
there was a very serious decline the
people that knew him best testify
under oath in front of all of us
as to the changes that they experience
with Terry
closest family members have seen those
relationships affected Terry's seen it
affected
again I want you to weigh this evidence
in the way that only you can
and I think that you can do it I've seen
all of you be very attentive I've seen
all you pay attention and we appreciate
that because this is a very real
situation for two people
the two stories that are at play in this
I also want you to remember
there's been a lot of talk about what
Jenny Sanderson said what Jenny
Sanderson reports but she's the one that
went on one of those International trips
with him
so it can't be too strange of a
relationship you're not getting the full
picture when you have excerpts taken out
of context from a deposition that are
rent to you you're not
she has three daughters they all love
him and they all said that unfortunately
we didn't get the chance to hear some of
the positives from Jenny
relationship is strong
she loves her dad
and he loves her
but she even said she's seen changes
now
yesterday you heard Terry Sanderson say
it's a hard thing to bring a lawsuit
against the celebrity
said they destroy your life and they
turned around and said it's your fault
it's your fault that this happened your
honor the uh I I object and would like a
little
conference and unless you want me to
State my objection right here I think
just overruled and you can make a record
later but let's let him finish
I don't want her lumped in with brothers
or celebrities
thank you judge thanks
point the finger at Terry Sanders saying
saying it's your fault you did this you
brought this on yourself
Terry Sanderson believes in Justice just
like you've seen right here it's been
waived all over
and he wants the wing of the scales the
same way that Miss Paltrow does
Terry Sanderson believes and I think
we've shown you
that on those scales
someone has facts that are weighing and
someone has a lot of fanfare that when
you really pry it it's a so what
nothing
so I charge you
and we thank you again for your time
hearing the evidence listening to all of
us listening to the coughing listening
to the objections listening to the
sitting through the sidebars we thank
you but now it's you it's on you
we invite you now to weigh the evidence
and we Empower you and trust that you
will weigh this evidence the way you've
heard it properly and find on behalf of
Terry Sanderson thank you
thank you Mr Sorensen
in a civil case
only eight jurors are allowed to
deliberate and reach a verdict
because this trial was scheduled to last
over this two-week period
um and because jurors may need to be
excused because of an emergency or other
extraordinary circumstances two
alternate jurors were selected in this
case
prior to going back and deliberating the
court is required to excuse the
alternate jurors
some jurors are relieved when they are
excused prior to deliberations but most
are disappointed
and even frustrated that they've
invested their time and energy in the
trial but are not going to be able to
deliberate
those of you who are excused those two
thank you for your service on the jury
remember that you're actually not being
you're not being released as a juror
until the verdict comes in because there
is an outside chance that one of the
eight during deliberations may be called
away for an emergency and so the two of
you that are allowed to leave what you
may be called back to finish the
deliberations and to vote on the verdict
form with the others
so please do not discuss the case with
anyone please do not read anything about
the case just keep the existing
restrictions in place until notice
further notice by the court
which will be after the verdict is
rendered
please leave your cell phone number with
the bailiff so that they can notify you
when the verdict has come in and even
give you the results if you'd like
again we we appreciate your time and
attention on this case
so those I've got in here all of your
names and I'm just going to look the
other way and pick two out
or your juror numbers rather
and so the two that are excused are
number 15.
and number 24.
those of you who are not being excused
right now you've been given all of the
evidence and instructions on the law
regarding this case
before you retire to to deliberate I
need to give you a few final
instructions first about questions
as you deliberate you may be tempted to
seek more information
if you do not have if or if you do have
questions please write a note and give
it to the bailiff and I will review that
note and the question that you have that
pertain to the case and I'll review it
with the lawyers and decide on how to
answer your your question if it's
appropriate however it's quite possible
and in fact it's probable that we will
not be able to answer your question
you should understand that no further
Evidence can be provided to you and the
instructions given to you contain the
law which you need to reach a verdict
based on the evidence presented to you
what to take into the Jury Room let me
first say that you cannot take your cell
phone and you can't have any outside
contact during deliberations so the
bailiffs will give you some time before
you begin deliberations to text or call
anyone and let them know hey I'm about
to go on a black you know be blacked out
here while we're deliberating and then
they'll take all of your cell phones and
they'll keep them in a safe place back
by your deliberation room
you may take the following things in
there with you your notes that you took
the jury instructions in any notes you
took on those jury instructions
all of the exhibits admitted into
evidence they are being assembled the
lawyers will agree that yes we do have
the this is the correct exhibits with
the clerk and then they'll be brought
back to you in a little bit
you're also the same with same with the
verdict form I have the original verdict
form it says original on top this is the
one that will be filled out and the
balance will bring this back to you as
well
when you get to the Jury Room please do
the following before beginning your
deliberations read over the instruction
on selecting a four-person and select a
four person and then you may begin
at this time I'd like the clerk to
administer the oath to the bailiffs
do you swear that you will take charge
of this jury and take them to some
private and convenient place where they
may deliberate upon their verdict
allowing no one to speak to them nor to
do so yourself unless so ordered by the
court and to return them to the court
when they have reached a verdict or when
so ordered so help you God
thank you you may now take the jury back
thank you
may be seated
thank you Council Mr Owens did you need
to make a record on anything on that
last objection
[Music]
yes thanks there was just a reference
it's hard to sue a celebrity I thought
that was an unfair statement given uh
this person this is a person here not a
celebrity and I thought it was unfair to
sort of slime her with
Hollywood
and the court anticipated that and and
noted
was what I was thinking about was the
fact that the plaintiff basically said
the same thing on the stand and I think
he was just repeating that so
as far as
well are there any exceptions that need
to be taken on the record otherwise
okay
I wonder if
there's been a motion filed by
some members of the press concerning how
to handle the reading of the verdict Mr
Raymond are you in the courtroom
Mr Hunt is that right why don't you come
up and present your motion
if you could first identify yourself
your bar number and then who who it is
you're representing
good afternoon your honor Jeff Hunt
my bar number is 58.55
I represent core TV ABC news CNN
Daily Mail the Associated Press and NBC
News
I'm ready to hear your motion we did
file a motion your honor to modify the
courts
um
Electronic media coverage order into
Quorum order which previously through
the trial has restricted EMC coverage of
council tables
and as the court knows this is a case
that's attracted substantial National
and international attention I think it's
actually been a marvelous opportunity
for the public to observe how the court
reaches decisions how cases are
litigated
and we all benefit from that that
transparency that accountability that is
what the EMC rule that was adopted by
the Supreme Court was intended to serve
and as your honor knows
under the EMC rule rule 4.401 Electronic
media coverage is presumed
within the limitations of the rule
subsection 6 of the rule there are
several limitations for not showing the
jurors showing minors not showing
exhibits that haven't been admitted Etc
council's table is not within subsection
six so as the rule stands the
presumption is that there should be
Electronic media coverage of council's
table and we just simply wanted to
clarify for the court that when the jury
comes in and announces their verdict
that the videographer and the still
photographer for the Associated Press be
allowed to show the public as everybody
here in the courtroom would see
council's table I mean that is the most
important part of the trial this is what
we've all been leading up to everybody
here in the courtroom will be able to
observe Council and the parties when
that verdict is announced and we simply
believe that consistent with the rule
unless there is an overwhelming and the
rule says a compelling interest not to
show the parties and the lawyers during
the announcement that it should be
allowed and the court should modify
the order to allow still camera
photography and the video coverage we've
participated with court tree V in over
30 years of Trials live coverage we've
never had once a situation where the the
public wasn't allowed to observe the
parties and the council when the verdict
was announced and that's for good reason
uh
you've had seven years of litigation as
I understand it you've had two weeks of
trial
and
the the most important people the people
that have the most interest in the
outcome of this litigation is the
parties in their Council
and the public ought to be able to
observe them when the when the verdict
is announced
and again under the rule your honor the
burden is on the party seeking to impose
an additional limitation
um under the EMC rule to come forward
with some
explanation for why that would be
particularly harmful
or prejudicial and there simply isn't it
any any reason for that if you look at
the reasons the the factors that are in
the rule all those factors fade and
waiver away in favor of allowing
EMC coverage of the verdict announcement
vision is happening
physically
sure where Wes would like to be
positioned the still photographer
imagine there would be a still camera
right here okay but without an operator
that is be remote is that possible I'm
not sure
if that works for still but the video
would just be as the video would
normally work right for
but it's for the still
camera
yeah there was a still camera up here
before Mr Hunt but I don't I don't know
how much control the photographer had
over that camera and it had a very big
long lens and it was focused on one
individual
he says he could fire it remotely from
that position the camera but can they I
mean if it's the aperture well I'm just
wondering uh if it would be if the if it
would be focused on one individual or be
focused on both Council tables at once I
mean how how do you perceive that
okay
so at this point physically what it
would require is a photographer to be
standing over here and taking pictures
is that what I'm hearing yes okay
okay
and I mean the court TV camera is very
unobtrusive I don't see it I don't hear
it it's a it can pan and move and and do
all sorts of things without anyone
noticing it I realize that right now
um I mean this will be the end of the
case so the the the concern of of an
interruption of the proceeding is
different but it's still there in terms
of decorum
um how how can we maintain Court decorum
and still meet the request it is there
you know but uh we can station the
photographer there in a place that's
unobtrusive the jury's here the focus is
going to be here it's going to be very
brief it's not like we're asking and why
can't why can't the still photographer
take Stills off of the Court TV feed
I'm not
they're just different I'll hear from
you I'll hear from both sides there's
just different modes of of capturing the
image the still photographers just set
up designed just for that the images are
richer and in your experience or your
clients experience how other courts
handle the still photography we've
usually had the still photographer
positioned in a place that's unobtrusive
and for limited periods of time and not
able to go in and out of the courtroom
it's just there
thank you I think I'll hear from you and
again but I just want to hear from the
party sure
Mr Sykes
you're on behalf of the plane if we have
no objection to this we think it's
reasonable
uh right now there's a uh this tripod
over here with the camera on it is
covered with a of a black robe like uh
two judicial black ropes here and I
think if Mr uh
uh bomber was to stand there
and we'll we'll take the screen down I
think that would be fine for us we don't
think that would be obtrusive or
violated for him so we're in favor of it
Mr Owens
thanks your honor uh
first amendment's important to us
there's certainly been a public benefit
I think to having this
uh
in the public sphere
there we've noted three violations of
the decorum order
the very first day my client walked in
to the court after I assured her there
would be no photographers in the lobby
there was one right interface that she
went through security
and suddenly one day at another camera
appeared and then a third violation we
felt I don't know if you found a
violation
but I have still photos of her being
taken just yesterday
so we're all for the First Amendment
the idea that the public
should see what we see the public isn't
seated
in The Well of the Court the public is
seated behind Miss Miss Paltrow
the jurors have an interest here this is
stressful for jurors
to have a still photographer standing
right where that screen is as if those
folks come in I think even if their
picture isn't taken I think it's strange
I think it will be stressful
Mr Sanderson actually has a privacy
interest here too
I thought it was insightful of your
honor to ask about how this would
physically change
if nothing would physically change
and if they're looking uh
at the defense Council
in its totality defense council's table
we would have no objection
Mr Hunt
so the defense wouldn't have any
objection if nothing changes physically
in the courtroom from the way it sits
right now that's fine but I still think
it would be unobtrusive and completely
consistent with court decorum to have
the still photographer there for the
minute or two that it took to announce
the verdict it's not going to they'll
have already determined their verdict
it's not going to add any additional
stress they have known that there's been
media coverage throughout the trial we
disagree that there's been any violation
of this Quorum order Council has not
approached me about that and we're not
you but I do I didn't even know you
existed in this case until
an hour ago it only represented the
media in Utah for 30 years
I know you but I didn't know you were
even involved in this case so
we're not here about that we're here
about my motion and it sounds like we
squared away the the court TV the video
we Dash your honor for the two minutes
unobtrusive Mr Sykes makes a good
suggestion of moving the the
the stand up and we think that that can
be accomplished and and the public will
be richer for it we're going to have
descriptions about the reaction anyway
the the Press is going to report that so
why not have the images in the video
that actually show what the reaction is
so the public can judge for itself what
the reaction is that's the most accurate
way to report this to the public thank
you thank you
well given the fact that there is a
presumption in the rule and given the
First Amendment the court will grant the
request as long as for the reason stated
for as long as that
that is used to sort of stand between
the photographer the still photographer
and the jury so we can turn that
sideways the still photographer can
stand quietly and I assume your camera
makes no noise
there's no flash
okay you can stand next to the uh the
existing camera then and when the when
the verdict is read
all right
is there anything else before we adjourn
at this time
uh can I throw out an issue that will
need to be addressed at some point uh
your honor has had a protective order in
place
in terms of speaking with the Press
after the
verdict is delivered
is that protective order lifted as to
speaking to the press or issuing press
releases
I ask because we've received a lot of
inquiries
I think the protective order and the
decorum order I think talk about the
evidence for instance depositions
being held confidential in perpetuity
but the Press issue
I think is appropriately lifted once the
the verdict is delivered so there you go
I don't quite understand your request
your clarification are you so you're
asking are you asking to continue the
protective order are you asking for
confirmation that the protective order
will be are you asking for confirmation
that the protective order will be
released as to the press as to the Press
we want it to be released we don't want
certain for instance depositions that
were taken
that were marked confidential anything
that was not for instance I have boxes
and boxes of things that didn't come
into trial right I don't want that I
want those held everything that was
marked confidential according to this
Court's confidentiality order remains
confidential correct in perpetuity if
it's been entered into evidence in this
court it's obviously not it becomes
public and then we do want you we we do
want to be able to speak to the Press
after the verdict you you may do you
have any objection to that Mr Sykes no
okay so so once the verdict is read
the the informal agreement between the
sides that they won't talk to the Press
until
after the case that's then no longer
there and they can talk to the press and
the Press can talk to Witnesses the
Press can talk to uh jurors if they so
desire and I'll explain that to the jury
and I'm going to ask the press to please
acknowledge and respect the wishes of
the witnesses and respect the witnesses
or the request wishes of the jurors and
if they don't want to to speak to them
or if they want to wait or maybe later
please respect that so I expect I expect
that'll happen I think that Pete just
mentioned
uh the decorum water prohibits any
cameras in the courthouse
I think that should be lifted
now I mean because it's cold out there
and wet out there
and they shouldn't have to be out there
and we shouldn't have to go out there to
talk to the Press if we want to well
I'll consider that but it's the reason
that there's the standing order that
they're not be pressed doing things
other than inside the walls of the
courthouse other than through the
through a decorum order is be or special
orders is for other reasons they're
security reasons things like that so
um
I'll talk with those that have some
control over that and get back to you on
that
anything else before we adjourn not not
finally adjourn but take a recess
okay so what what I'm going to do is
when I'm
alerted that there is a verdict
I will let the head of security
operations Chris Palmer know that that's
happened and he will then let all the
Press know that in approximately 20
minutes or longer if we need need that
at least we'll wait at least 20 minutes
before we bring the jury in and read the
verdict so if the lawyers will please
leave a cell phone number contact with
Jody then we'll have we will call you as
well if you're not on premise
all right thank you we're in recess